Donald Trump has arrived in New York
City preparing to surrender for his uh
arraignment
and you know we got to with Charlie Kirk
is hanging out and we were talking
earlier so I think I think Charlie might
disagree but I I was saying this earlier
on my morning show that if you want to
explain to people just how close we are
to societal collapse or the precipice
just tell them ask them what happens if
Donald Trump doesn't surrender
34 counts what happens if Donald Trump
just says no okay well we know he's
going to New York he's no he's going to
do it okay here's the other scenario
what happens if a judge says we remand
Donald Trump to the custody of the New
York criminal court system meaning he's
going to jail and they're not going to
let him out until the case is resolved
what do you think happens to this
country the front runner for the
Republican Party a former president for
the first time in history that's the
precipice because I could not imagine a
peaceful resolution if either of those
things occurs and that's what we're
dealing with right now and it's not just
the indictment in New York we now have
news that the Secret Service is
scheduled to testify against Donald
Trump in Washington D.C this is
pertaining to classified documents
they're not going to stop that's how
close we are confidence is about to
break down so we're going to talk about
a lot of that plus we do have some silly
social issues I guess because Elon Musk
changed the Twitter logo to Doge and
then Doge spiked like 40 or whatever
yeah yeah so uh before we get into all
that head over to timcast.com click the
join us button to become a member if you
want to support our work directly and as
a member if you join at the 10 level
after six months you will get access to
the VIP chat in our Discord server which
allows you to call into the uncensored
after show and ask questions as a member
you'll get access to the Discord where
you can hang out talk with people and
communicate and we use that sort of the
chat the chat will appear on the
uncensored show live stream but if
you're a member for at least six months
you get that auto upgrade or sign up now
at 25 bucks and instantly join the VIP
Channel where you can call into the show
we screen everybody so we only do a few
questions per night I don't want to get
expectations too high we try to get as
many people as possible but uh we're
really excited for the community
building aspect of the Discord and we
did Just Launch castbrew.com our coffee
company so things are going really
really well thanks to all of you so also
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and as I already mentioned you already
heard Charlie Kirk is hanging out
tonight hello and Libby Evans is here
cheers you know we'll go in order you
want to introduce yourself hi everybody
I'm Charlie Kirk I host a radio show and
podcast and run Turning Point USA I'm a
big big big fan of what Tim's doing here
appreciate it man and Libby Evans of
course I'm Libby Emmons I'm the
editor-in-chief at the post-millennial
and human events glad to be here with
you Charlie oh my gosh I'm Ian cross and
Charlie good to see you man I'm a big
year I love you too that's why I can we
haven't seen since I haven't seen since
am fest wasn't that great that was so
fun yeah we had Steve Bannon I mean it
was awesome swore more than any person
in the history Tim cast in a short
period today it's great thanks for
having us that was just so awesome it
was really sweet I just want to point
out that Charlie is wearing a button-up
shirt collared with a tie Libby is
wearing a button-up shirt slightly more
relaxed I'm wearing a button-up shirt
completely unbuttoned and Ian is wearing
a I guess a lavender what is that
purple velvet everyone dressed as you
would expect exactly maybe we'll talk
about religion today man I want to also
it's Holy Week what what is it what holy
let's get into it okay
we'll do that later because we got to
talk about Trump getting arrested and
all that we got surge pressing buttons
yo uh let's just roll all right here we
is the story from the AP Trump returns
to New York to face historic criminal
charges so as I stated in the opening of
the show if Donald Trump made the
decision not to surrender I think this
country would get ripped apart New York
would be complaining he's criminally
wanted we want Florida to return them as
with any criminal Florida Ronda Sanders
would be like I'm not getting involved
in this I'm not going to do it the feds
probably wouldn't move in but Donald
Trump I believe
cares about this country and so I think
he realizes what would happen if he does
defy this this indictment I also think
he sees a tremendous benefit as his
polling has skyrocketed as fundraising
has skyrocketed so he's saying you know
what I'll give you exactly what you want
and you will regret it so the latest
story is President Trump returned to New
York from his Florida State money to
face historic booking an arraignment on
hush money charges they say that but
it's 34 counts so it could be more
they say already months into a Third
campaign to reclaim the White House
Trump and his advisers seem to relish
the attention cable networks followed
his plan at airports in Florida and New
York with video from there I mean I view
this as an as a complete backlash a
complete backfiring for Democrats he's
raised he raised five million bucks 4
million bucks in a day 5 million over
two days he's his polling is up 30
points 33 points Ron DeSantis has
completely collapsed against him in the
GOP Primary Trump could not have asked
for something better to help his
campaign
except the fact he might go to jail
besides that it's great well here's a
question I have for you do you think
Democrat jurors in New York will acquit
Donald Trump no
no I mean so he's going to jail well no
not necessarily I mean first of all
there's a lot of
legal uncertainty here it could be a
judge could say this is a misdemeanor
not a felony it is a New York judge so
that might not happen there could be a
long process of jury selection 34 counts
can get reduced down to five or six
there's also sentencing right so I mean
God forbid Donald Trump actually gets
convicted but if that ends up happening
you have someone who's never been
convicted of a crime before so you could
pull you in front of the judge like hey
this is a should be a misdemeanor that
you call a felony the precedent New York
is saying that if you lob Molotov
cocktails at police cars you don't get
serious jail time we give 21 000 to BLM
rioters my client should get community
service which I think will be hilarious
to have Donald Trump do community
service but uh as kind of everyone would
love him right no I mean like go clean
up the Brooklyn Bridge and it would be
the most watched live streams Palestine
20 20 years ago if someone like Donald
Trump was charged and convicted with a
misdemeanor and then the sentence was
going to be community service the lawyer
would say perhaps our client can make a
large contribution to various charities
in the community in lieu of community
service and they would say yes being
Donald Trump I don't think they would do
that and your point about BLM while
correct I don't think applies to people
in New York City no I'm just saying
there's a broader question legally I get
that the whole trend is relaxed on crime
but come on you can hear that there's
there's an equal protection there's a
14th Amendment claim that can be made
good luck no I agree with you I'm as
cynical as you are too but at some point
you're going to run into some backstop
at that could slow at least slow this
down and especially and then also Tim
before you go to jail you get an appeal
and the appeal courts the appellate
courts are a lot saner than all right
the original the the original criminal
court so Trump is not allowed to leave
the state
okay that's that's a potential do you
think that's going to happen so I cannot
imagine a circumstance where New York
jurors I'll quit Donald Trump no I can't
imagine that I cannot imagine a
circumstance one just takes one yeah but
then it's just a mistrial and then it's
well then but so that we're dealing with
time right so they'll say I'm I I do not
I right now Donald Trump has gone to New
York voluntarily he's going to surrender
I'm glad he did
I don't believe there's a strong
probability a judge remands him into
custody because of the fear of what
would happen if they do but it would be
just they don't do that in New York
anymore but that did you hear we're
talking about Donald Trump but but
outside of that the political
ramifications I don't think it will
happen however I do think there's a
possibility the judge says Mr Trump
you own several high-end properties in
New York City where you can easily
reside do not leave the state
during for the duration of this trial he
will not be able to campaign and they're
just going to say whether or not you
campaign for president is not our fault
you are being criminally charged
that would be that's a possibility right
and I got to be honest when it comes to
the molotov cocktail thing I even
envisioned a possibility where when
Trump's lawyer politely argues to the
judge New York City's laws are very
lacks in terms of crimes committed this
is not a violent offender and then if
they reference just recently two young
people were firebombing police vehicles
and were given an opportunity the judge
will say how dare you question the
motives of people challenging the the
white supremacy of this nation Donald
Trump is a white I would not be
surprised if you're more cynical than I
am did you see what it is a New York
City judgment I don't I'm just not as
I'm not as like forthright and just
thinking the whole legal system will
collapse here's why I think you might be
wrong Tim just to play Devil's Advocate
is that the room for error here is very
limited every comma is going to be
dissected by the legal Community here
people could get disbarred this is not
some sort of Fringe case in Ithaca New
York they had everybody involved in this
is going to be examined on the Appellate
level they could lose their law license
there could be complaints filed against
them you might be right the whole system
might be so corroded and might be so
poisoned however I think that because of
the I think I think this is my
prediction that they're going to just
blink and just keep their head down and
act as if this is a regular crime and
not do anything too unusual and say this
is the law and we follow it this is
precedent fine you can go out no bails
jail 34 counts hold on that not
necessarily they're misdemeanors though
well they're yeah they're misdemeanors
one felony no 34 accounts doesn't mean
you go to jail by the way I mean it's
just you could have one action that you
have 34 different points for example you
could get charged for fraud and you make
34 phone calls and it's all on the U.S
attorney or on the charging documents of
the prosecutor to determine how many
counts there are there are U.S
attorney's offices in America that are
well known they're notorious for 99
count indictments just to do it so why
so let's look at this why would they
indict Donald Trump in the first place I
I have a theory as to why it's Revenge
for winning winning no it's more than
that it's revenge for stealing the
Kravitz center from them
we know this in the psychological
literature trauma is a very very
powerful thing these people are
traumatized and humiliated that night oh
yeah they thought that was going to be a
wedding ceremony think of it they wore
their best clothes they thought they
were glass ceiling yeah no literally for
people to understand this is Hillary
Clinton's yeah the party yes and it's a
literal glass ceiling
corrections I get all messed up Javits
thank you for correcting me yeah for a
second I was like wait what are you
doing oh yeah jab it's Kravitz that
Kravitz is in Palm Beach so the Javits
Center and they thought they were going
to a wedding and they went to a funeral
and that but that is those massive
psychological damage and Trauma and they
soar a Blood Oath that night do not do
not mistake the pettiness in New York
political Elite I I was re-watching the
debates 2016 Trump Hillary and when he's
like she's like you guys better be glad
that someone with Donald Trump's
temperament isn't in charge of the law
in this country and he's like because
you'd be in jail and then he just looked
at her and they looked at each other and
I'm like that's why they're going after
him it's Petty it's pathological it's
personal and so Donald Trump
psychologically scorned these people and
they said we're gonna get you back and
now they looked when he's arraigned
tomorrow there will be a population of
New York that says it took us seven
years but you stole that night from us
and you might have got Amy Coney Barrett
you might have got Comey Kavanaugh you
might have got all these different
people on the Supreme Court but now we
got you but but that implies this is the
end of it I don't I don't I don't
believe no no well they have additional
charges I mean the doj as you said the
doj is now looking at obstruction
charges the secret service is going to
testify against them in DC no it's not
the end no no but if you were talking
about New York politics we're talking
about who is in Alvin Bragg's ear the
New York City Elite primary Hillary
Clinton that is very Petty very personal
very political this is about revenge and
there's there's other games to be played
here with Jack Smith at the doj and the
woman in Fulton County because of the
phone call Trump made which was
perfectly fine
so then there's another theory that
they're doing this to try to take Trump
off the chessboard
um I'm not as convinced of that one this
one just seems to be Revenge politics
perhaps but I just don't see a
circumstance where they can set this
this chain of events in motion and then
appease their constituents by backing
down
no I think that's right and therefore
the room for error is almost nothing and
when you overcharge and create a crime
with a quote exotic legal Theory as
Maggie Haberman said on television
you might let a lot of people down again
yeah the the legal system in America is
designed to allow people that are
overcharged that have good legal
representation to fight it now you might
be a cynical about New York as possible
I do not have faith in the in the
pattern of behavior we've seen in the
New York legal system but everything
will be examined every single charging
sentence and syllable is going to be
hyper critical so
there's a potential I imagine of this
going to an appeals court correct or
even being escalated to U.S appellate
federal courts Supreme Court potentially
Supreme Court I think I think there's a
decent percentage chance that actually
happens
but in the meantime
you I think we're going to see hyper
partisan politicized law enforcement and
Judiciary
because too much of what I see is the
what I refer to as the freedom faction
which consists of disaffected liberals
Libertarians conservatives believing
well there's rules and the rules say it
must be done this way and then it's like
dude they fire bombed a car and then got
let go no I'm not even making that
argument I'm just saying that there's a
lot of there's a plenty room for error
for these people that think that Trump
is 100 going to prison that a lot can go
wrong that is they're gonna oh they're
over charging they're creating a crime
that doesn't exist they're upgrading a
misdemeanor to a felony also Michael
Cohen is going to be your star witness I
mean the only way I see this going in
Trump's favor is if after conviction it
goes to an appellate court with a trump
appointed judge and that gives the
Democrats an out of his own appointee
excuse himself yeah well that that's
their out to avoid going all the way
down yeah but it would be a state a
judge it wouldn't be a trump appointed
judge it wouldn't be that's what I'm
saying it would have to only be if it
goes to the federal level having some
kind of federal court intervening how
would it get to a federal level
Federal prosecutors had already declined
to prosecute this right I know I
I do not see a circumstance where New
York political establishment says we've
decided to let Trump go I just don't see
it I do not see a jury of New Yorkers
being I think you're right I don't
disagree with that but I also this this
ends up with Trump facing sentencing
potentially potentially I just I'm not
I'm not saying it's certain there's a
lot that can go wrong
this is this is in for them I mean and
go right for those of us that believe in
the country justice but how I mean I
could go to the list again right they're
over charging but so who's going to
intervene and say this is an overcharge
the Democrat D.A the Democrat lawyers
the Democratic population a potentially
a judge that doesn't want to get
disbarred or put in front of discipline
from who in New York State Court this is
interesting because you're saying nobody
is going to follow the rules that exist
no and you're in New York that they're
Democrat no New York judge is sitting
there thinking
well
the the the Democratic establishment
that controls New York state is going to
disbar me they're thinking I will be
disappointed if I don't put Trump well
look there's
you might be right
but considering how insane these charges
are and how damaging they are this is
far from a we're assuming what the
indictment is we don't know exactly
what's in it yet it's far from a signed
sealed and delivered case right and
here's the thing Trump's going to try to
stretch out the timeline here and he
will use it to his Advantage every one
of these local actors is now going to be
under a national Spotlight and National
examination I'll give you a couple
examples everybody now working in the
DA's office that's going to touch this
case their social media histories will
now be examined they're not going to be
comfortable with conservative
freedom-loving media shining a light on
them and if they're hey hold on
Kyle Rittenhouse
is largely free today because of free
media that was on the street and we
shined a light and we exposed them but
he was also in a it was a Wisconsin
court in Wisconsin but very strongly
conservative uh no not so much that's
not totally true I mean Wisconsin as a
Democrat Governor it's more sane than
New York I'll give you that for sure I
what I'm getting at though is I think
the New York political Community is
going to be shocked at how big of a deal
this is going to be how much their
failures are going to be put on
Spotlight and these people are over
charging and we know that yeah but that
only but then maybe it's so what by the
rules man I don't think they're playing
by the rules so why would they care
about overcharging because you're going
to find a couple people that still have
some shame
shame who do they fear
so you live in New York you're a judge
who lives in New York City you know what
you fear you fear Auntie for coming to
your home with bricks and Molotov
cocktails let me let me have a counter
argument if it's that signed sealed and
delivered why didn't Cyrus charge Trump
on these why brag
I don't know because it's not there's
not unanimity that this is a good idea
that's why well here's what this is a
risk if it was Cyrus would have done it
he was a way better prosecutor way
better respected way more kind of White
Collar Law Firm Alvin Bragg is like a
street Thug that has become attained on
going after Trump correct one so and now
he's doing it but the fact that the fact
that other DA's passed on this case
shows that there's a risk element here
that favors Donald Trump or because they
didn't a new guy gets in who's
escalating things
well that that could be the case but
it's not as if Cyrus wanted to get him
indicted he would have loved nothing
more I mean the guy was a total Trump
hater he would have been the darling of
the New York City Elite but maybe this
is not so much about risk as it is
escalation maybe this is that's a
separate argument though right so is it
about Trump or is it about trying to
distract from the looming currency
collapse and banking crisis to incite
violence amongst the American right so
that they can clamp down on us and say
CCC these people can't handle Freedom
they can't handle Liberty we're going to
try to raise the temperature in the room
because the American currency is about
to collapse let me pull up the national
Democratic party wants this to happen or
do you think brag is doing this despite
them potentially not wanting it that's a
good question too I mean I I think they
may not want it to happen I think that
too they may be saying look how much
money he's making his his polling is
skyrocketing you need to chill out and
this dumb local level guy is being like
I'm winning you know so maybe but to
your point uh I want to pull up the
story we have this from pix 11. once
again New York PD uh NYPD cops ordered
to patrol in uniform prepare for
mobilization after Trump indictment so
this was just the end of the last week
as it was being announced Trump was
going to head to New York but this has
been a consistent story since the
announcement of the looming indictment
before it was confirmed New York police
fully mobilized every every officer told
to be in uniform and get ready my
question is for what you know what's
interesting is we had our Trump
supporters going to go around or what we
had a reporter out there last week who
went out to the courthouse the night of
the uh like with the with the indictment
I think it was um
Wednesday she went out on or maybe it
was Thursday I don't know anything
anyway uh she went out and she was
talking to some of the cops who were
stationed outside the courthouse and
they had all said they were talking to
her about it and they said that they
were told that this wasn't going to
happen
for like another month and then all of a
sudden they were all called up they all
were told that they had to pull doubles
and they had to get out there right away
and they were all kind of pissed they
were like we didn't think this was
happening now that's also a way to
agitate people and that you're just
agitating the cops and their families
that is agitating so the way it must be
looked at it's an indictment trying to
lead to incitement
this is a direct incitement campaign
where they're trying to raise the
temperature in the room to try to spark
a backlash that they want to be violent
who is they the National Security State
the Deep State the regime media because
right-wing violence makes the regime
more powerful I'm at the point where I
just don't see how it how it matters no
one on the right like the bifurcation of
culture in this country is is complete
none of us here are swayed by any
arguments about right-wing violence we
know what antifa does we know that I've
experienced it absolutely and For
Heaven's Sake conservatives don't even
want to go around waving flags around
peacefully they barely want to go
outside and protest at all if anything
some do but mostly they don't that's
right but the narrative among the left
is they truly believe it so I was uh I
was at a a casino called Maryland Live
this past weekend and I was playing
poker with the boys as I often do and
talk about and the guide to my left said
that all of the people on January 6
should be executed um my goodness no
kidding like he got so someone brought
up politics this is a regular guy he
doesn't know much about politics he's uh
executed executed not kidding he's he's
uh these are like grandmas being like oh
look at the pictures well there were
violent guys out there wouldn't want to
be a lot there would be a lot of dead
federal agents sure but listen so there
was violence there's a riot there's
people fighting with cops I've seen
worse say antifa protests but I get into
the capital on one side of the building
the doors are open but the cops people
are let in and I'm talking to this guy
because someone brought up the economy
which led to someone bringing up Joe
Biden and you're not supposed to talk
politics at these tables because of what
happens and then I asked the guy what he
thought and he was a really funny guy he
was really cool we were getting along
having a great time just having fun some
jokes were made some fun poker hands and
then we got into he got really angry and
it was just like those people what I saw
with my own eyes in January 6 they
should all be executed every single one
of them that's treason against this
country and I saw what happened and I
said I was like well you hear about how
happened on 529 and he says no what's
that was like when the when the leftists
the far left they they tore the
barricades down at the White House that
fire to St John's Church so
firebomb the guard post and then the the
Trump was forced into an emergency
bunker and he goes I I don't know what
you're I don't know anything about that
and I'm like that's it right there
this guy was not political he said he
hated all politicians but the messaging
that reaches him is
insurrectionists or traitors and I have
no idea what antifa is yeah
and imagine a new wave of riots called
the Trump riots
that's what they want to see bubble up
but I don't I just I just I just can't
see it I can't well you were the one Tim
that you think the country would
collapse if they remanded him but not
because people on the right are going to
romp around with guns it's probably
unlikely very unlikely the reason I
believe that if Donald Trump did not
surrender okay the country would
collapse is because
a country only exists based on
confidence it is an abstract idea that
tethers people together you look at
other countries where they do not have
confidence in the government you end up
with Civil War you end up with
corruption with bribery Etc and then
very little in power of the government
other than guns if Donald Trump stayed
in Florida and announced to the nation I
do not find these charges to be
legitimate these are political it's a
political persecution in a Witch Hunt so
I'm going to completely ignore it
what precedent would be set nationally
that New York was powerless to stop
someone who committed what they say our
felonies and Florida refuses to
extradise yes so that's that's two
questions so it's speculation because
it's not happening but it's interesting
first the precedent would be you file an
extradition order the second is Florida
has to choose whether or not to honor it
and they probably would you think that
you think Ron DeSantis that's the
question I don't think the governor has
all that Authority I don't know how all
the particulars work I think that he
wasn't going to get involved yeah
not getting involved and dishonoring a
Interstate extradition order are two
different things
can you imagine yeah this is all
speculation but I think it's helpful but
but let's just entertain these two
potential outcomes the extradition order
denied Rhonda Santa sang We're not
involved which I think would be a pretty
ballsy and cool thing to do but that's
absolutely I completely agree but but
what does that mean for law enforcement
as a country the other scenario I want
to sure on imagine Ron DeSantis saying
we have no choice I am hereby ordering
State Police to Mar-A-Lago to arrest and
transport Trump against his will to New
York that would be insane exactly but
that's what would have to happen hold on
we have we have a precedent of
a couple things so the idea of a state
or a locality
saying that other people's laws don't
apply to us is not new yeah California's
doing California is doing it with the
gender stuff Vermont I'm just trying to
do it Los Angeles San Francisco Portland
Seattle Chicago Boston Philadelphia are
all Sanctuary cities where they defy
federal law and don't work federal
agents so that's not a perfect example
but this idea of blue States and blue
cities carving out their kind of own
place to you know play if you will so
that's one argument the second thing is
what would happen in a standoff between
a former president and Florida State
Troopers it'd be impossible to know
goodness the question the question would
be what would be Trump's end goal which
is why Trump is going to New York
because Trump the reason why Trump is in
New York is he sees massive upside to
this because Alvin Bragg is doing what
the other DA's decided not to do he's
raising money he's getting points in the
polls and Donald Trump is now seeing
himself is now being positioned as the
Martyr of the American right yep that is
that is so wild and being the Martyr is
incredibly popular and martyrdom is a
way to win popularity and what do you
think the American left is thinking
about it
depends who's who you're talking to Mark
Elias or your average crazy person in
Brooklyn they're cheering for it well
yeah Mark Elias is probably not cheering
for it that's a separate issue he's much
more strategic that's the question about
the national Democratic party is
interesting yes the average Trump
derangement syndrome Democrat is saying
finally Joy Bahar on the viewers fell
into it but these people are savages and
they they they they're never going to
stop in their bloodthirsty quest for
revenge and that's my point
we have two completely bifurcated
worldviews and cultures one that is
calling for Injustice and one that is
saying it's good that Trump turned
himself into Injustice it makes no sense
well no no I'm not saying yeah I I I see
it both ways so Define the Injustice you
have to you have to have the ends in
Minds right your final and formal causes
developed and I don't think that would
have been necessarily prudent for Trump
to say you got to go send the Troopers
after me it would have felt very like
George Wallace you know 1960s or 70s now
having Florida stand up and have the
entire Florida State Troopers Stand Down
against an extradition order that would
have been interesting but what I think
does need to happen and the only mature
response that I've called for for quite
some time is Republican DA's and
Republican AGS need to start indicting
and investigating members of the
Democrat crime family one that we can
all agree on is fraudulent is the BLM
criminal Enterprise that materially
benefited with a hundred million dollars
and the sum summer 2020 and they've been
untouched wasn't act blue being used to
facilitate donations to some of these
organizations correct yeah and act blue
is a harder case to make but we can say
just with black lives matter Global
Network with Patrice cullers we now know
there was material charitable fraud
under any sort of reading she was buying
all those houses yeah six million dollar
mansion in Malibu for a content creator
and the money went missing I guess the
money went missing all these sources oh
yeah you could just just to make track
check me on all of it right there was a
bunch of that she has a multiple
multiple real estate Empire right she
also paid her was boyfriend now husband
for security services for a healthy sum
you can fact check me
um on that it was quite a lot yeah NBC
News is not what I would use as yours no
but you know that's why it's just going
to take you more time to find the
numbers BLM leaders condemn allegations
of mismanaged funds that's that's a
that's a word salad headline they're
condemning their own Mystery but it was
even reported in it
here's L.A times black lives matter
leader accused of stealing 10 million
dollars there we go sure that that right
there so let's just pause there and
that's actually a separate one that's
not BLM Global Network right but my
guess is that somebody in a red State
don't what's his name again
this is that the global Network
Foundation Bowers sure
um why is there not widespread
investigations and indictments into the
BLM charitable fraud now that matters
because if we if we want to have the
promise of equal justice and the 14th
Amendment it's like okay you go after
Donald Trump who has become a martyr of
the conservative right there you go
Washington examiner is a great site so
that's BLM Millions unaccounted for
after leaders quietly jumped so I'm
I deal in the 501c3 world every dollar
is audited every dollar we have an audit
committee we have a CFO I can't even
sign checks it takes two people in the
organization right we do 990s we do the
IRS very very high standard of financial
accountability at Turning Point USA this
year is outright charitable fraud now
why does this matter because the counter
argument said well Charlie that's just
some charity no no no
BLM was the kind of vehicle of choice
for the activists left so you go get
Donald Trump in New York then fine we're
going to go take BLM and put them on
trial and go through the charitable
fraud of how they raise 100 million
dollars and got 83 billion dollars in
pledges from Corporate America and where
did the money go that would be that's so
much that would be a prudent Act of
deterrence that would actually I think
open up
the legal conversation and that's just
one example of a hundred that I think a
few years ago
there were people telling me that what's
happening today would never happen
because the government would not allow
it that the government was Secure that
the the Deep State apparatus the
whatever you want to call it does not
allow these kinds of things because it's
destabilized sort of things like Trump
being arrested like Basics like BLM
Summer of Love who says that like this
was in 2018 are you reading like
keyboards or something no like wait what
the these are these are mainstream
conservatives I I've never heard that
but sure you've never heard people say
that the country can't collapse that no
I'm saying that Trump can't be indicted
like I don't I haven't heard that yeah
so so in 2018 the idea that Donald Trump
would actually be impeached they were
like they won't allow something like
that okay well impeachment is different
than indictment but sure continue yeah
well but indictment wasn't even on the
table there wasn't even a criminal
charges that were okay I think I
misunderstood what you were saying in
2018 when I was talking about how we are
heading towards a collapse or Civil War
and again I stress I didn't make the
idea a Princeton Professor was talking
about the Colts of wore numerous Outlets
were talking I see what you're saying
people were saying that can never happen
the government is an entity in and of
itself the Deep state it will not lose
control in that matter it doesn't care
about the left doesn't care about the
right and now what are we seeing as the
years go on the federal government is
being bifurcated into mostly an
establishment left and more new there's
no right there's no opposition there's
no opposition there is just the hyper
partisan hyperpolarization of federal
government and so what we end up seeing
today is Donald Trump just flew to New
York to surrender on bogus criminal
charges there will be no opposition to
that
this will get worse as the years go on
there is no reason to believe that these
people in power are going to decide to
pull things back so they don't have to
why why would they what is the mechanism
by which they will say hey let's let's
slow down here so the only way they stop
is if we stop them and so I agree if the
current trajectory continues
everything you just said will happen I'm
a big believer in Free Will and agency
and the ability to do something so I'm
going to use my platform to call on what
the only thing I think that could stop
it which is deterrence which is to get
DA's and AGS to indict Democrat crime
member families if we don't do that
everything you're saying is true but so
my my issue there is this country is so
bifurcated what you're describing would
just be the exact same thing to them as
it is of course it is it's equal and
opposite reaction you punch us we punch
you and then it escalates to further so
the question is stabilization what
escalation is better than being pummeled
well I I
my heart is saying we're not going to
stop until you stop and and the issue is
true if you have a friend that smacks
you a lot and you're like if you did
that again I'm going to smack you back
but they do it again and you smack it
back they stop that's deterring but this
is not no I completely it's a fair
warning you're like what you're doing is
wrong I completely disagree there's
there's numerous examples about history
where the the pushback just led to a
escalation until war broke out and
people all killed each other with a
Civil War in this country they didn't
just say whoa this Vines is growing too
much guys that's the greatest stuff
that's a good thing
argument is good and Sherman decided to
March to the Sea rather savagely and and
Savage is an understatement yeah it is
he said I got an idea I'm so sick of
these people I'm going to burn their
cities to the ground kill children and
Destroy Farmland all the way down so
they starve and die
of scorched Earth Warfare so the no no
no
so let me just frame it though because I
hate to reduce things to binaries but
the American right has a choice
option one keep doing what we are doing
which is to send strongly worded press
releases and op-eds and hope things get
better
Choice two indict indict use political
power and hope it gets better they're
both bad options I agree I like them
totally agree the the Forgiveness Arc
for Donald like if you're really
pummeled and beaten down by Society so
hard and you still stand up and forgive
people for it that's a message that will
resonate for thousands of years I think
that's powerful not gonna happen it
could I think I think they're lying in
the polls too they're they're trying to
make the argument that they want Trump
to be the nominee so they can beat him
in 2024 but they didn't beat him last
time well I mean they did beat him once
they beat him last time but they don't
but but they don't have anything right
now there's no one Biden can't do it
Biden didn't campaign he hid in his
basement there was a lockdown where
melon ballots were sent to everyone's
home I totally agree they don't have any
of these tools so unless H1 h5n1 hits
yeah and then they do another lockdown
like a Slime Flu 2.0 or something Biden
is done do you remember the town halls
people in their cars right right yes
that was the Jeeps front of the stage
yes Biden is a proven failure the
country is in shambles that guy I
mentioned who talked about executing
j6ers also said it's Biden's fault the
economy is bad so my point is just they
can't try this game twice and I do
believe they're going to try they're
putting out polls where it's like if an
election was held today Biden would win
DeSantis would beat Trump but Biden uh
they're saying that DeSantis would beat
Biden but and Trump would lose to Biden
and they're trying to make the case that
we should support DeSantis for the
primary I think they are lying once
again in the polls so can I validate
what you're saying yeah can you go to a
website it's number
270to win.com
yeah this every 10 years we do a census
as mandated by the Constitution most
people don't know this but the map has
slightly changed in Trump and the
Republican favor for the first time for
2024. so the maps are good for three
cycles and then you read do them good
for three Cycles actually two cycles
redo them well what do you mean it's
right right here it's saying let me show
you okay so let's make let's let's
assume Texas goes red is that fair
enough to say oh easily and Florida yep
okay let's assume Pennsylvania goes blue
please and then New Hampshire goes blue
and then all of Maine goes blue really
yeah let me show you Michigan goes blue
I know what I'm doing here so and
Minnesota goes blue and Minnesota goes
and then Nevada goes blue and Nevada
goes below Iowa goes red Iowa and Ohio
goes red and Ohio and North Carolina
goes red and that's okay so what you
have right here is why they fear Trump
all Trump has to do is win Arizona
Georgia and Wisconsin and he's the
president of the United States three
states he won in 2016. three states that
received Zuckerberg money three states
that have elected Statewide Republicans
and three states that have more repo
well two states that have more
Republicans registered than Democrats in
Georgia and Arizona and one state that's
50 50. this is why the Democrats are
indicting Trump the map has changed if
we if this was not the map in 20s what
I'm telling you are we going to say uh
so Nebraska had that one District I
turned it red well no if you even if you
don't it goes 271 right if it's 271
without it with it it's 272. yeah and so
you 270 to win is all you need so let's
know this so therefore
Donald Trump can't not only can he win
the presidency this map heavily favors
the Republican to win the presidency
this is interesting even even the the so
the only real consideration I think I
don't even know if Arizona is
necessarily I'm I'm not as worried about
Arizona I live in Arizona right it's
it's it's a challenge you think so okay
it's a 50 50 state Cinema is going to be
a formidable Senate candidate if she
runs as an independent
that's good for Republicans it's good I
think Arizona with the proper get out
the vote ballot chasing operation which
we can talk about
is gonna be fine My Philosophy my
hypothesis is the entire United States
election comes down to three states
comes down to Seven Counties and this is
why they fear Trump so much this is not
a national election mind you
Pennsylvania's blue yeah you're right
you're right in 2016 Trump won with I
think 88 000 votes across the three
states but he needed he needed a
Michigan or a Pennsylvania in addition
to a Wisconsin because the census map
favored the Democrats because of the Sun
Belt surge it's because Florida has
gained population so significantly it's
a red State because Texas has a New York
and California and Illinois have lost
population the stars have aligned where
the Republican is now in a much easier
spot to win the White House than ever
before you better believe Mark Elias
knows this that's why Elias and the
national Democrats are not thrilled
about this indictment they're just
saying what are you doing to win those
three states what do you want to do this
when to win those three states and this
is helping them there oh yeah his polls
have gone up oh not only that but upper
middle class white Suburban voters are
not thrilled about the idea of over
prosecution because they kind of get
that what that means that's a that
resonates that's that's a democrat-based
thing let me tell you the funny thing is
this guy I'm talking to who's that
execute the j6s which is insane to me
also said this country over prosecutes
well so there you go and it's it was
this is an interesting thing it sounds
like a walking contradiction AKA a swing
voter absolutely he was a PA swing voter
well that and so you look at it because
people say how do we win Michigan how to
win Nevada how to win Pennsylvania you
don't need to and so you look at the map
you then you then Focus very precisely
there's not just a path there is a great
probability Trump becomes president so
let me pull up this story we got this
from Newsweek Donald Trump's Secret
Service agents set to testify against
him report a number of Secret Service
agents are set to testify as part of a
federal investigation into Trump's
handling of classified documents Brett
Baer said on Tuesday the grand jury
appears uh appearances are related to
special counsel Jack Smith probe into
the handling of classified documents at
Mar-A-Lago
so yes what uh for those who are just
tuning in or missed the last segment
what Charlie is saying is that actually
what is it you said Georgia Arizona
Wisconsin that's it Arizona with the
four Givens which is Iowa Ohio North
Carolina Florida which I feel
comfortable all will be in the
Republican category it's looking very
good for Donald Trump to win in 2024.
not only do we have the indictment in
New York but it looks like federally
they're gearing up for some kind of
indictment as well and that one can be
trickier for ballot access
the New York one will not prohibit from
actually becoming a candidate being a
convicted Federal felon is an open
question really yes but I thought I I
thought that wasn't the case I thought
uh the the talking point was even if he
gets charged it depends on what you're
tried with if you're tried with
Insurrection well they can't try him
with it classified doc but the
classified documents bar you from
running for office correct yes then how
could Joe Biden run again well because
they won't charge him yeah they're gonna
they've already defended what he did and
criticized what Trump is ridiculous but
the Insurrection one is interesting I
don't think they're going to charge such
a ridiculous claim but just for a
thought experiment because that's what
we're doing that's what they try to get
marginally Taylor Marjorie Taylor green
on in Georgia and Madison cawthorne
correct is because a lot of these
Southern States actually have
criminal code Provisions you can't be on
the ballot if you were charged
Insurrection it's a Civil War era yeah
exactly that's being more convicted of
of it I believe yeah that's right cubic
not charged with you're you're correct
so what's the what are the chances
they try and charge Trump with the most
minor of minor j6 related quote unquote
insurrections like how they're getting
people on trespassing calling them
insurrectionists
what happens if they say misdemeanor
um um what do they call it um
like uh medicine what if they say
menacing in relation to January 6. it's
unclear legally but here's the greater
concern remember that strange argument
we had of whether or not California can
tell you you have to be on the ballot
based on your tax returns yeah right
Democrat primary States
are going to use these charges as a way
for ballot access in these states that
Trump would otherwise do very well in
like New York what do you mean how so
don't be surprised if New York you're
going to find out if the Democrat Party
wants Trump or does not want Trump to be
the nominee very soon and I think they
do not want him to be because he brings
out a different voter no one else can
bring out if the New York State Assembly
gathers and they say if you are charged
with a felony you're not allowed to be
on a primary ballot in the state of New
York now what would that mean now they
might lose it might be a silly argument
if they're successful
well Trump would then not be able to
even compete for the primary delegates
for the Republican nomination of the
state of New York interesting is that
just mean don't even try
it means that that he would if they did
that then whoever the second place
person would be would just be on the
ballot right we're in our scientists
yeah or whoever hasn't announced he
hasn't announced but he's probably going
to run but we're inspecting we're in
speculation World here yeah and I think
it's somewhat helpful because we're now
building out kind of a universe of all
the different dimensions of how they're
attacking Trump contingencies I actually
think this is really healthy it's kind
of how a war room talks in a the best
possible way but I'm going to just say
it again
Arizona Georgia Wisconsin it's less
about messaging it's less about the
person it's about the Machinery not the
Dominion machines but ballot chasing
yeah or you have early voting agree look
at John fetterman John Federman is
United States Senator
not because of his Charisma yeah I mean
and I can't say he's coming back to work
April 17th yeah the full force of John
fetterman how could anyone
watching any of this not be like double
WTF mate yeah I think it is that in in
what world is a Democrat like I'm
totally fine with whatever it is with
John fetterman and yeah the the level of
cognitive dissonance with John Federer
and it's insane I just I just he's a
walking brain dead Frankenstein who
can't understand anything that is said
to him Libby have a little empathy for
the guy you know he look I I look I feel
bad for him I I am saddened by his story
it was his dream he wanted to make it to
the Senate he had a stroke I wouldn't
wish that on anybody what we need to do
right now is in our heart of hearts have
empathy for this man and just let him
vaguely
take him out of this stressful stressful
position and give him Comfort I would I
believe that Republicans in this country
should pledge right now one million
dollars towards the the retirement of
John fetterman to relax peacefully and
carry out his men medical treatment at
home
and then have somebody else be the
senator granted I know the reality there
is that it's his wife and so we don't
really want that either
want to be the senator she seemed to
want that after she had that stroke and
everything my point is simply like in
all seriousness I do feel bad for the
guy because he really wanted to be a
senator and then he had a stroke and
it's got to be like that's the worst
thing in the world man I mean that's a
bummer but I don't it's insane that they
would put him in office who have voted
for him well what was really insane too
was when it turned out that he couldn't
understand anything that was said to him
and that everything needed to be on a on
a computer screen translated so that he
could read it and when we mentioned all
of us mentioned that this was perhaps
going to make being in Senate remarkably
difficult everyone accused us of uh
ableism and saying that his disability
you know was some issue ableism works if
it's like someone was born paraplegic or
something and we want a wheelchair
around to help him right not when like a
senator who has to debate make decisions
is having a his brain is a problem like
this isn't Stephen Hawking over here you
know what I mean yep but there are
people who were like I would prefer that
and so that's why I call it cynical or
whatever I just I do not see
a mending of the bifurcated culture in
this country I think it's got to start
somewhere at the top and I last night I
was thinking like if Trump and Biden
could get together and just be like you
know what we're Americans first
high five a little bit that's all it
that it doesn't seem like much for them
but like the world will be like oh
America is the greatest I think that I
think that would never happen well you
know but I do think that you're right
that the culture is remarkably
um remarkably divided we don't watch the
same TV shows there's no common culture
that we have our religions our
Collective religions are incline there's
nothing that unites us I mean when I was
a kid we'd all watch the same TV shows
on Thursday night I could even probably
give you the lineup you know what I mean
it was like The Cosby Show and and
that's why I don't think it comes from
the topic on the radio it comes from the
bottom I do not believe what's causing
the divide in this country is leadership
I believe it is algorithms on social
media that manipulated young people
creating uh so so as I've explained
numerous times ten-year-olds get on
Facebook in 2008 or whatever and are
immediately shuffled into two different
realities they are now growing up there
was never a point where someone just
like decided you know what I am a
conservative I am a liberal what was
happening was young kids were being fed
two different versions of Reality by
Facebook now they're a voting age there
is no bringing those people together
because they live in different realities
they don't even understand reality in
the same way exactly or the same
language they don't have the same goals
for a world view or anything like that
right so how do you if someone's entire
being their brain their body was built
on this country is nothing but white
supremacy and someone else is built on
America is a great freedom fighting
Nation civil rights Etc
you are not going to reverse 18 years of
mental development
yeah not overnight but but not even in a
few years
the decline in critical thinking in
education too that's an issue as well
like I'm thinking the long game if
there's a lot of people that will
mindlessly follow Donald Trump and Joe
Biden and do what they say which For
Better or Worse that's how people are
built sometimes and if if they see them
being kind to each other and promoting
like forgiveness they'll just mindlessly
do it and that's like the beginning and
then their kids will actually realize
why it's valuable and in 20 years Donald
Trump Jr will be president or something
like that like it doesn't have to be all
Donald Trump senior today right now or
nothing like it's we're kind of creating
the environment
I never saw it uh presidential Camp uh
campaign I've never seen like candidates
go at each other until 2016. I've never
seen them hate each other until 2016. it
was very out of character for the United
States you know I think you're on to
something with that too because there it
used prior to that it did seem like uh
Republicans and Democrats at least had
the same goals for the country right
you're right like blowing up kids
overseas funding the military industrial
complex
Tim on this I think that I'm not saying
that's a they had good goals but they at
least had the same goals yeah it was the
unit party yeah so two thoughts on this
because we're having a conversation on
how to heal the land that's kind of the
summary of what we just talked about
here
the first is I don't think Donald Trump
caused the division he revealed it he
revealed 50 years of neoliberalism of a
fake currency and endless Global Wars
and invading the world and inviting the
world and re-domiciling American
industry overseas he just exposed it and
he did it in a very blunt sometimes
clumsy but awfully direct way who gave
the American population
a prognosis that was honest you guys got
tumors everywhere and I'm going to
remove them and then all of a sudden
he's the problem for even mentioning
that we have these tumors and yeah we
are really divided I think we've been
divided for quite some time and I think
there's a couple reasons for that
there's an interesting theory that we
can explore which is can a large
Republic sustain itself meaning is this
just inevitable when you have 330
million people and five you know almost
4 000 miles of land mass 3000 miles of
land mass is it is it just unsustainable
the founders were concerned about I
always hate that question because I love
this country and I love Oliver you love
the size I love them you're like
Jefferson you want to go from Ocean to
Ocean see the shining sea right and yet
you know Jefferson being a completely
walking contradiction was the one that
wrote in the Anti-Federalist papers he
was afraid that large Republican
governments can't work and then he
bought Louisiana
so again that we're all walking
contradictions in some sense which
should give you comfort that even our
heroes were contradictions in some ways
but how do we heal a land this is really
the question of the Statesman
it's a question of someone that is able
to identify the problem cogently and
then be able to come up with some form
of a prudent and healthy and realistic
solution and so Abraham Lincoln called
it the crisis of the house divided right
that's similar to what we're living
through now but I actually think we're
even more divided in some ways than we
even were leading into the American
Civil War at least there was a Christian
country back then now we have different
metaphysics and we have all sorts of
different types of views but we have
some things working in our favor which
is the great hope is that we can
de-escalate the national politics and go
back into hyper local community and just
say I don't like the person in Portland
I don't like the person in Wichita but
I'm not going to try to imperialize
their life
until we get to that the project is
going to fall apart absolutely I was
thinking about the word democracy and
how it comes from demos which means the
people and it's basically I hate the
word democracy yeah it allows the mob to
make decisions for the whole I'm not a
fan of democracy it's it's pretty brute
it's pretty like kind of rudimentary and
if we could evolve into like a
technocratic republic where we have
technology like apps where we can govern
ourselves locally I can hear me out of
this look and he's like hear me out
because we could always go back if the
power goes out we're still Democratic
Republic but we can upgrade and govern
locally because what you just mentioned
is local governance if we could somehow
send our tax dollars around locally
through a local app that's free software
you can watch the code nothing's
tracking it
um and if the power goes out you can
still set your representative to the to
the central location to govern the whole
from there because that's the least
worst of a bad government system but I
think we need to evolve our Republic
what I think you're hitting is
interesting in the sense that there are
different forms of government that might
be different for different people if you
leave the federal government out of this
equation people can then have a
structure that might better fit their
values the Amish are going to be a lot
different than you know the secular
nihilists in Brooklyn where the American
Republic has gone wrong is we have an
imperialist government that is invading
the communities and invading the lives
with an Ever
urgent pattern of behavior that is
telling people what to do and that is
really the incitement and then the one
symbol of that Donald Trump
is being martyred we also I got to
respond to what you were just saying
because while I do agree we shouldn't
just assume the founding fathers hit the
nail on the head perfectly in every as I
think it was the best ever but yes I
think it was the best even now the
structure and form of it without a doubt
the best and we could talk about why I'd
love to and I'll simplify it you've got
a Council of Elders Supreme Court you've
got a a group Gathering a communal
Gathering of Congress and then you have
the executive the Monarch all of these
different forms of government they had
seen they were like let's do all of them
and have them challenge each other and
create this networked style system it
was brilliant but what I'm saying is as
time changes and Technology changes
there's probably ways to improve however
my challenge to you in on the idea of
technocracy is or our technocratic
government whatever you want to call it
we look at how we created these
algorithms on YouTube with the intent of
creating more games of Game of Thrones
YouTube said 10 minute long content High
watch time that's what we want instead
of getting Game of Thrones what we got
were weird videos of Elsa being chased
by The Joker and Spider-Man with no
English because more people could watch
it if there was no language because it
crossed language barriers it had
multiple keyword generating figures in
it if we go the Democratic route the
only actual outcome is either a human
being is in control of the system that
we think is technocratic or we create a
mechanism by which the technology AIDS
us and then it runs Haywire because it's
impossible to predict
um you could put in stopped apps like
you need your face your social security
number to use the app it's public data
so you can see who's posting what and
that's only local someone would have to
have Supreme control over that system to
correct errors and maintain the system
it would be open source so the whole
Community would be policing the software
that seems like Wikipedia like a total
disaster and right what will happen is
you will then get uh 51 attack or
whatever it's going to be a network
system where Democrats are going to
register a bunch of people they're going
to say hey download this app on your
phone which will then make they're gonna
they're gonna say this is called Swing
Vote and if everyone signs up we can
control the system I'm thinking more of
something like public Square where you
can it's just resource distribution I
love Public Square yeah so like a
government app that's like open source
free software that is resource
distribution and then someone gets in
government and says that Ian Crossland
guy take him off the app no no it would
be we would have our own Local app so
like every city would have its own
version or every locality could have its
own version and they could interoperate
you have a great heart this is never
going to happen but I I I I I love the
heart that you have for trying to build
this it's just the problem is the power
of having an app that control all will
be corrupted by a by a person
um it's all going to get corrupt like
the voting database has been corrupted
no I agree yeah it's just when you have
power it will corrupt absolutely as Lord
actins so we're looking for something
that can is the least corrupted of a
corruptable system like nothing's
Incorruptible right but if if that if
you think the technology will smooth out
the inherent corruption in man it does
because writing is a form of technology
and before it was just barbarism and now
we have an organizations do people still
lie with their pen true people yeah
exactly I imagine it was much worse
before 3000 BC I think that was just the
exact same I mean we we
it helps you see yourself so you can
judge your own heart
video video being able to watch yourself
and see yourself speak you immediately
know what you're doing wrong
I hate watching myself that's the why
because you're seeing the faults I don't
think that's but I I would challenge Ian
because I think there's a deeper
philosophical point that I think Tim was
hovering over the reason why the
Constitution and the Declaration are
just as applicable today is because it's
built on Eternal truths things that are
always true what is what is a human
being what is our purpose here generally
are we naturally good are we naturally
bad I don't think a piece of technology
in fact I think technology amplifies the
worst aspects of human behavior here's a
couple certainly is right now here's a
couple problems that I think that piece
of tech we were just talking about won't
solve is that our Republic is have
become out of control in that there's
700 Representatives 700 people 600
people in Congress 535 350 million so
there there's like 700 000 people are
trying to be represented by one guy
totally you can barely right you
represent yourself essentially so that's
interesting I that I don't I at first I
was like get rid of the House of
Representatives and people I know that's
too extreme uh Mike Gravel who is
Senator from Alaska unfortunately has
passed because the man's was amazing and
I love them created this idea of
national initiative creating a fourth
branch of government where we would set
up a system where the American people
can pass laws into Congress as well as
the right that's a terrible idea too
well uh you it would be like you know 50
Representatives one from each state and
they could come together you know
whenever convenient that's why I'm not
I'm not a more law guy so but having the
the uh Monopoly of law in the hands of
700 600 people but let me tell you how
the founders thought it would be until
the 17th Amendment the state
legislatures used to pick the Senators
so that used to be your through line
17th Amendment yeah we went people State
reps senator
now you say well the people pick the
Senators but now we know they're just
pseudo celebrities and they raise a
bunch of money and these elections have
become just corrupt you know contests
but the founders design which I would
love to repeal the 17th amendment I
think that'd be amazing agreed right is
now all of a sudden senators are
appointed
by the state that's how it worked until
Woodrow Wilson 1917 I think it was
passed and it was way better because
then all of a sudden you're right one
senator for 800 let's say one senator
for seven million people no no you went
to your State Rep to complain about your
Senator because they could recall the
senator at a moment's notice that was
the original design and you know your
state senator because there's many more
of them and they're at the local level
precisely and these Senators at any time
could be called for hearings or called
for recall by the state legislature
you're not representing West Virginia
what are you doing you know that
actually does make a lot of sense
because we don't have a way to hold our
senator's response accountable other
than to just not vote for them
if we still had the 17th Amendment
Republicans would have 58 seats in the
U.S if we didn't have that that's what I
mean if we got rid of it let me I want
to say something as to what Ian was
bringing up with um 775 000 people per
representative so there's something I
refer to as the scaling problem that
people and fans of the show have heard
me say a billion times but for the sake
of those who don't please bear with me
if a hundred celebrities were gifted a
brand new iPhone extreme and one percent
of those phones were defective that's
one celebrity going on Instagram saying
my phone's broken well no one cares
they're gonna buy that sucks for you bro
like your phone broke that happens a
phone broke I'll say they give up 100
million phones with a one percent margin
of error now 100 now you have one
million people posting on social media
about how their phone broke and
everyone's going dude what happened all
these phones are broken same margin of
failure considering that now consider
politics
Alexandria Kaiser Cortez represents 775
000 people about 24 or 20 percent of our
district are conservative these people
get zero representation but 200 and some
odd thousand people in that District can
take over whatever they wanted
the amount of police that are in New
York
would not be enough no matter what if
every single conservative individual
said no taxation without representation
we are not getting represented
representation by ocasio-cortez she
rejects our values so we reject her now
you all of a sudden have 200 000 people
marching through the streets of New York
and the police have no way to control
that same percentage of descent but
hundreds of thousands of people not
getting any representation is is cause
for chaos and concern big time so I'd
like the idea of people representing
themselves directly I don't like
Democrat I don't like direct democracy
because the mob is dangerous the
collective is interesting the collective
can move together pretty well if they
have good organizations I don't know I
agree with that you think collectives
are are not good well I I I I think that
they collectives could be as Madison
wrote in I think the 51st or 54th uh
Federalist prone to Madness I think
that's about right the couple of times
that I was involved in arts collectives
uh I wanted to tear my hair out and run
screen from the building which
eventually I did she wrote specifically
about the urban areas of America at the
time which have only gone worse he said
they have a proclivity to the insane and
a posture to the uh the word was
beautifully poetically put but he said
that they the mobs will descend into
match Madness quickly and I think that's
true I mean for example there's a great
book by Douglas Murray called The
Madness of crowds I believe that's the
name of the title right Madness of
crowds you could fact check me on that
because there is a the collective can
make bad decisions very quickly I agree
that mobs and crowds okay crowds become
mobs mobs are dangerous but Collective
communication and like open source
database like GitHub that's a collective
movement I see so you're talking more
about a small D democratized system
where people can input data and allow
the information to win yeah look at
Wikipedia good luck ideally it's just
local the the ideally you're right but
look at Wikipedia it bends towards
tyranny it sure does I don't I don't
know about Wikipedia it's not open
source it's it's like uh I'm pretty sure
Wikipedia is open source the promise of
Wikipedia was that anyone could become
an editor and the internet will edit
itself the reality of Wikipedia is that
only people in the club become editors
and the people in charge can remove or
edit anything they want you read Tim
Poole's Wikipedia which I would not do
or Mine mine's a horror show mine's
actually not that bad okay mine's a
horror show it's like a drive-bye now
everyone's going to go look at it and
it's terrible Kelly J Keynes she's a you
know women's rights campaitor in the UK
hers basically says that she's a Nazi
yes that's right and New Zealand
politicians believed that and advocated
for protesters to go out and protest her
let women speak event and they nearly
you know they
you guys are right Wikipedia is open
source one of the funniest things ever
was when I had a journalist asked me
questions and they were some this this
they want to do an interview with me and
I said you know please have your your
journalists do their homework on me
before coming and when they came they
asked a bunch of fake questions based on
nonsense from Wikipedia like when did
you invent the Zeppelin which is the fa
like yeah because the meme is for like
five six years Wikipedia claimed that I
built a Zeppelin and I was like I did
nothing in the sky I did not do this
thing yeah like they said they claimed
that I built a zeppelin drone
modification for aerial broadcasting
which I never did and then journalists
would ask me about it because it was on
Wikipedia and it was made up it was
insane and you couldn't get it removed I
once went in there and said guys I am
Temple I never did this they said you
are not a reliable source you're not a
reliable source for whether or not
Zeppelin you are not allowed to be a
source for yourself because bias so
Wikipedia of course is completely broken
in that concept now to be fair
like a year ago we did build a zeppelin
to retroactively make it true and then
they wouldn't put it back so there's a
difference between open open areas where
you can go do stuff on and open source
software code so like you might have an
open place where people can go and be
but you're patrolling it and policing it
in a way that people don't like
but I think that like so like that would
be Wikipedia for instance is a place
where people they they regret it sure
yeah so but if the code is available so
that I could spit up my own Wikipedia
tomorrow and I have my local Wikipedia
and this like yo this is what we believe
in this area man I mean this is just how
we see the world that I think is a lot
better than trying to just
Focus all the data into one big open pla
open platform
and we could maybe do the same with
government because I feel right now
Congress is Wikipedia they're they're
deciding what is getting passed into the
Senate they're deciding what's getting
said no to and it's it's too much
control of information that's an
interesting question we all agree
Congress has broken the question can be
why
and I think there's multiple answers the
17th amendment I think solves the Senate
question there's other answers I think
that are important I think campaign
Finance absolutely plays a role and I
say that as a conservative we were
talking well I think it's corrosion
American politics the nationalization of
politics is a big problem for us and the
example I like to give is when you'll
see a local uh of someone running for
congress the federal level say I'm going
to clean this town up send me to DC and
say wait you got nothing to do either
yeah yeah when we send you to DC you're
going to talk about war and stuff and
federal budgets representing our
district you're not going to clean this
town up you have nothing to do the only
way to clean up the town is for them to
get a bunch of money and for them to get
a bunch of money
no but like let's say you have a
congressman Federal Grant or something
yeah you have to like you have to pack a
bill with pork for your District that's
how you yep I guess that's what they do
that's what you do what is it about the
national initiative you guys were turned
off or at first were you not interested
in are you familiar I brought up earlier
Mike ravel's idea to create a fourth
branch of government well first we
already have a fourth branch of
government that's the bureaucracies and
they're unchecked unelected and they do
great damage so this would be a fifth
Branch the fourth branch is the doj IRS
EPA the permanent government someone
told me the corporate media was the
fourth Branch maybe maybe we have six
branches seven yeah but the the media is
what the the four it was supposed to be
keeping a check on power the fourth
Branch to give quote unquote the power
to the people would only be duplicative
of what the legislative branch and the
executive which are directly supposed to
be direct Sovereign to the people so
here's the instead of creating a fourth
branch of government where you could
pass laws why don't we restore the
promise of small our Republican
government which is say the federal
government should not be doing this and
you send it back to the States one of
the reasons why Congress is so broken is
that they meet too often
neoliberalism has empowered Washington
DC beyond our wildest imagination and
the original project and this is why I
think we're at in 2023 States created
the Federal Government the federal
government did not create the states and
we're in a place now where everybody
thinks the federal government created
the states and that is not true people
also think the federal government gave
us our rights which is also not correct
and so
I I don't want to get too far into the
example because I haven't thoroughly
read it or heard the arguments or
counterpoints but my initial reaction is
that it's a bad idea
restoring states rights and putting
power back to localities I think can
de-escalate our tension can
de-radicalize our politics can get us
back to live Live and Let Live and leave
me alone
and could hopefully restore Liberty I
see no other path to Salvation I some
would agree I some would disagree the
challenge I suppose is what we saw with
the Civil War when you had the attempted
expansion of slavery and you end up with
Bleeding Kansas so let's try and apply
States divisions to a modern era if we
have a people say people tell me all the
time Federalism is the answer a weaker
federal government more power to the
States and it's like okay then someone
from Texas will be in a relationship
with a woman who will get pregnant she
will get mad eight months in and say I'm
gonna flee to Colorado to terminate the
life of this baby
the guy in Texas is going to be like
that's illegal under Texas law but and
she'll say then I'll go to Colorado and
you can't stop me now you're gonna have
a question of what do either state do
Colorado will say the woman can
terminated the baby at eight and a half
months and Texas will be like that's
kidnapping and murder is Texas going to
send troops into Colorado to save the
life of this man's son because a woman
wants an abortion there's also Democrats
people view that is insane that don't
get an abortion if she wants no matter
what age we're already there we're
already out there well it's a crisis is
looming right now that's what I'm saying
but so so the federal government being
stronger and preventing extra like
you there's there's no what I'm trying
to say is I don't see a solution let's
imagine a strong federal government
takes them and from Colorado and says
you can't kill the baby you're right
Texas resident Texas law says this this
is kidnapping and brings her back now
the left goes insane saying women are
being forced to give birth let's say the
federal government stops Texas and says
the woman is free to live where she
wants and she's getting abortion
let's say there's no federal government
you're going to get a dude let's let's
let's step outside the abortion uh
debate and let's talk about the trans
kids thing let's say it's for real in
California and and let's say a man and a
wife of a kid she decides to the kid is
trans and takes him to California
without the the man's permission and the
federal government says we will not get
involved the question is at what point
does some father say I will not sit back
and wait for my son to be castrated and
then get a posse and bring him to
California
like the conflict will happen with
people fleeing other states in this way
well you know what's interesting about
this there's some breaking news you
should look at by the way what's going
on just apparently the D.A just leaked
the indictment oh good the indictment
all 33 points I didn't mean an arub.com
good Interruption since we're live uh
I'm on Trump's telegram Channel
so where can we find it Twitter we'll
search for it let me can I read Trump's
statement is that okay yeah okay wow
district attorney Bragg just illegally
leaked the various points and complete
information on the pathetic indictment
against me okay all right great I know
the reporter and so unfortunately does
he this means that he must be
immediately indicted so he's calling for
the indictment of brag now if he really
wants to clean up his reputation he will
do the her honorable thing and as
district attorney indict himself well
where is the leak well I don't think he
leaks he links to the lick but I'm sure
it's on Twitter somewhere he will go
down for it he will go down in judicial
history and his Trump hating wife will
be I'm sure very proud of him D.A Bragg
just illegally leaked the 33-point
indictment there are no changes or
surprises from those Elite days ago out
of the grand jury no crime by Trump what
a mess Brad should resign now this says
34 felony counts for falsification of
business records felonies fourth yeah 34
felonies none of these accounts are
misdemeanors but they up they upgraded
upgraded it due to the uh what was it
like election
stuff the campaign Finance regulation so
they applied a federal law to a state
statute so what I think is really good
Palestine this whole thing is yeah and
what I think is funny too is that it
would be a campaign contribution for a
federal race right which is governed by
the Federal Election Commission not the
New York not the New York D.A but also
the idea that uh president Trump's
campaign would have been adversely
affected by him allegedly having had a
relationship with a porn star is also
ridiculous I don't think anyone would
have cared about that like I don't think
that they're addressing that information
was necessarily there's so many attack
vectors here that are just so silly yeah
there are a lot of them
Class E felonies which is the lowest
level of felonies I'm just going to
challenge everyone do not fall for this
34 that's what I'm garbage so it's like
if there's one Financial crime and then
they sent out a massive email to 34
people they could be like but the 34th
thing is a total PR move to try to get
you to believe that this is a much
harsher more serious crime I'll give you
you an example let's think of a crime
that and there's going to be no
handcuffs and no money let me think of a
crime that we all know of that I could
give you a really good example of okay
uh O.J Simpson okay let's he did it but
that's a separate issue but you could
have a 400 count indictment for fleeing
the police and running a red light and
you know he was in the Dodge Durango
remember that white Dodge Durango or
whatever he was in yeah right Bronco I'm
sorry thank you for the fact check
um that that would be a 400 count
indictment right but it's really
centered on one or two events does that
make sense so that you can extend an
indictment again this is why
prosecutorial overreach is so incredibly
you know severe and such a danger to our
society is that this 34 count thing is a
PR Masterpiece because if Donald Trump
was indicted on one count but 34 sound
serious did he break into the embezzle
money did he also do wire fraud did he
and remember a lot of the statutes in
the way the Crim criminal code is
written is not about the actual crime
itself usually it's about all the
supporting different criminal codes they
can get that you tripped the wire in the
process of committing the crime right so
the old adage is that they got Al Capone
on taxes that that's a bad example the
better one is that they've overwritten
the criminal code they've deepened it to
such an extent why are fraud check fraud
you know falsification of Records lying
under oath obstruction of justice that
eventually it creates these counts that
can give the prosecutor an advantage
does that make sense yeah absolutely
it's like uh getting having your bank
account go to a negative and then every
day you make a payment and you just keep
getting these negative charges over and
over and over again but it's really only
because that one no that say it was done
unjustly yeah that's right that's that's
a good example and so the the this 33 34
count thing is is brilliant we found the
leaked indictment or is Trump just I
think it was Jesse Waters who was
reporting on it I haven't found anything
on Twitter why would he leak it to Jesse
Waters
not that he's showing it that he's
saying it happened he may be just
referring to what Trump said so I've not
seen anything on Twitter I searched for
it didn't find any uh searched Google
Twitter I didn't find anything so
you know maybe it's circulating among
journalists but you see what I mean you
saw the statement he wrote right
um yeah Jesse Waters apparently I think
was just quoting Trump perhaps saying
that there's more evidence that Bragg
committed a felony than Trump
okay well Trump seems pretty forceful in
this statement and Waters was on air two
hours ago so I don't think that's right
I think that Trump just got a heads up
from a reporter that this indictment's
about to drop in a store or a reporter
emailed his teams my guess we've got the
indictment I know the reporter and
unfortunately it's Maggie Haberman I can
almost guarantee it there's only so many
reporters he knows that he would say he
knows I will put money it's Maggie
Haberman if I'm wrong I will finish this
glass of wine would rag have just given
a reporter the indictment I mean think
about it how many reporters has
proximity to the DA's office on this
beat that works the New York circuit and
also knows Trump that narrows it down to
Maggie Haberman unless I mean there's
other reporters too but my smart money's
on Maggie Haberman about to drop a story
so I would keep your eye on her Twitter
feed yeah I could be wrong I could be
wrong it could be the worst takeover but
that's just based on his statement he
probably got an email to his press
office hi this is Maggie Hammer of the
New York Times just wondering if you
have any last minute comment here you
know we just received the indictment in
full and then he's trying to preempt it
with his statement that's my I guess is
that that's he says it's a felony to uh
leak in indictment I have no idea I mean
the New York Times via Haberman remember
received Donald Trump's tax returns in
October 2020 illegally and was never
held criminal criminally accountable for
that the same thing they went after
James O'Keefe for remember they rated
James O'Keefe's apartment for allegedly
receiving
a document a diary which is not even he
said it was stolen yeah it's stolen even
though government tax returns are a much
higher privacy threshold than a private
diary that you obviously didn't care
enough about to get out of a halfway
house it was a halfway house she was in
it was like a recovery home like
roommate or whatever yeah I don't mean
to slander her but yeah I mean some sort
of thing
um so we'll see but my guess is you're
going to see a story drop here rather
momentarily that's me reading between
the lines Don Haberman I don't know
that's my guess
it could be CNN by the way they were
leaking to CNN previously too so but my
guess is if Trump says I know him
remember Maggie got several Oval Office
interviews with Trump and that's one of
his you know
that's one of his uh you know and by the
way we have to remember that if the
foundational crime allegation against
Trump falls apart all of the 33 charges
crumble so if you're able to get to the
essence of the charge which is did
Donald Trump break Finance campaign
Finance law by administering 130 000
payments let's go through the fact can I
go through the facts surrounding this
Tim is that helpful yeah yeah let's go
okay first of all he did not write the
check Michael Cohen did
Michael Cohen is not a trustworthy
witness this guy Michael it's Michael
isakov isakov from The Washington Post
uh drink the water I gotta drink this
water I was wrong that was your bet you
know if you drink more than four ounces
of water at a time it makes you feel
like you have to but I was right about
the fact that a reporter was about to
drop yeah it's with Yahoo news Yahoo
news
exclusive Trump to be charged Tuesday
with 34 felony accounts but spared
handcuffs and mug shot that doesn't no
wait wait wait wait the spared mug shot
the mugshot would have made him so much
money when was that published three that
was published an hour ago yeah just a
little bit ago but are you sure this is
where they actually got the leak this
doesn't look like A source told Yahoo
news this is from this just came out
this is not you don't think that's the
thing because they have his statement in
here I could be wrong I want a copy I
want like a yeah I want a docu cloud
upload right right you know what I'm
talking about exactly but here's the
other facts okay that Michael Cohen
administered the payment okay Michael
Cohen wrote in an official letter to the
FEC the Federal Election Commission that
this payment was on his own behalf and
Donald Trump never reimbursed him so the
question will be do they have a record
of Donald Trump reimbursing Michael
Cohen for a sum or a like some that
could convince a jury that that Michael
Cohen lied to the FEC he lies all the
time the third thing there is nothing
illegal about administering an NDA
there's nothing illegal to it Bill
Clinton did all the time CEOs did all
the time rappers do it all the time
right it's it's done quite frequently
half of them so this it might be the
isakov story which would be strange but
he's saying that uh they're Class E
felonies of falsifying business records
up to four he's in prison the New York
law enforcement says it is extremely
unlikely a first-time offender would see
jail time there will be no arrest there
will be no cuffs there will be there
will be no uh mug shot are there going
to be cameras in the courtroom I don't
ask today to not have cameras in the
courtroom yeah Trump's saying he doesn't
want it yeah and remember issakov was
one of the original Steel dossier League
stories remember so he has an end to
that's right law enforcement and Intel
agencies but anyway the whole the Crux
of the argument with Trump will come
down to intent and also the quality of
their Witnesses I don't know who Alvin
Bragg is going to bring you know called
to testify other than like Cohen yeah
Michael Cohen who's a convicted liar
went to jail for a line in front of
Congress and so you know this thing if
they can if the elemental charge which
is falsification of business records
right is is the cult is the whole ball
game here regarding did he pay Cohen
back for it I saw a check a year later
paid for 35 Grand it was 130 000 payment
he paid Cohen Trump paid Cohen 35 and he
was doing other business with Cohen so
how can you draw one to one it's all on
Cohen's testimony and remember Cohen's
own lawyer Costello or something this
guy went on Tucker he was very
persuasive said Colin's a liar and
Cohen's such a liar that he goes he goes
and signs away his attorney-client
privilege
so that his lawyer then is able to go on
television and say yeah everything he
told us under attorney client seal let
me just tell you this guy's a complete
liar they added the statement after the
story dropped oh is that right this is
likely the story they probably reached
out to Trump's team and said okay it's
Michael issakov so it's not Maggie
hibberman stand corrected Chief course
it was a good guess though spokesman for
um Trump's legal team has not seen the
indictment or been briefed on the
details
yeah I don't know if they actually have
a copy of the indictment though if they
did right it seems really weird why
would you not like why would you not
work for Yahoo news yeah well
but why would you know they must pay
well
I guess I thought they were just an
aggregator you know they guess they're
doing their own stuff well yeah they got
a scoop apparently
it doesn't there's nothing new here
yeah Jack wasovik has a tweet he said
the we've we've you know I'll paraphrase
this country is irrevocably damaged
there's none coming back from this yeah
I think that's right I don't agree with
that it's just we've seen how damaged
it's been over the last 70 years by the
banking Federal service you know that
the way they've made the Federal Reserve
is scandalous the way that they went to
that island and had Congress started
over Christmas of Jekyll Island yeah and
speaking about what's going on today
we've never seen anything like this
happen to a former president and there's
no question it's political unless of
course you gain from it politically
that confirms my argument Democrat
politicos are going to say it's not
political because they benefit from it
end of story when they see when people
see like oh look how horrible this
country has become for instance with
this banking Scandal you know where our
country looks like it's on its way to
bankruptcy you got to ask yourself do
you want to maintain this country now
and and I think that what helps is
perspective because I was just watching
about North Korea last night and you
know it's very possible remember that
auto warm beer story he came back all
comatose they think they just the North
Korean government just poisoned him and
sent him back so that he couldn't talk
yeah they just killed him in prison they
poisoned him bio weapons like that's the
other side of the coin if we lose this
Republic well and the what was it the um
North Korean leader Kim Jong-un which
one is is that is uh his daughter wore a
Dior like a whole Dior Ensemble to watch
a a missile test recently yeah I love it
which is there it is terrifyingly
concerning you know when Cult of
Personality goes out of control and one
person gets control of a small and she
gets Dior outfits and everybody else is
starving so you know rule of law law and
order it's not just law it's Law and
Order if your law produces chaos then
it's a bad law so if the country is
irrevocably damaged if there's no coming
back from it then what we need to create
something new there's no going back what
people need to do is but who's even make
money have families
do virtuous things repeated do virtuous
things repeatedly daily and be
disciplined and anchored to things that
are self-sufficiency being as
subscription as possible and then uh
find someone who's who's legally allowed
to give you Financial advice and have
conversations about what do we do in
these trying times so I was thinking
about the the question we were talking
about with Colorado or the trans kids in
California and really these are not
legal questions I mean we can pass all
kinds of laws we can enforce all kinds
of laws but this is a problem that
exists in people's hearts you know yes
like that's my point about Civil War
yeah that's a big issue here like if you
have a woman who to use your first
example is going to spite a man that she
once loved by murdering their
eight-month-old child before it's born
but this happens all the time there was
a story just recently this is right but
what I'm saying is that's a problem in
someone's heart that's not that's not
something a law can fix that's something
that's about the decline of morality the
decline of values the decline of love
you know there you go
literally just Google searched what you
said
VA mom who killed daughters and plot to
exact revenge on husband and called to
tell him get 78 years she she shot them
in their beds she drugs and shot them in
their beds this story I saw this five
days ago yes five six days ago so when
we're talking about states that allow
the killing of children and states that
don't
my fear
is that you will get a father who will
say something as simply as she has no
right to take my son and kill him I'm
gonna get the boys together and we're
gonna go and stop her from doing it
they're not gonna I'm not saying I'm not
saying they're gonna come out and get
guns and be alike it's time to ride boys
I'm saying they're gonna be like let's
go find out where she is and stop her
from killing my kid and that's going to
escalate from there the state's going to
be like she's allowed to kill your kid
too bad even if and I'm talking about a
point which the child is viable and can
survive outside the womb and the
husband's saying just let's instead of
killing it let's just deliver it and
then I'll take the baby and she says
nope it's gonna die now this woman goes
to prison because the babies were were
five and fifteen five and fifteen oh my
gosh a baby that is viable of living on
its own
can be killed in these States I am not
arguing the morality of abortion what
for those that are listening I am
arguing simply that there will be
existing vocabulary though you're using
the proper wording well but but if a
baby can survive on its own then it's
being killed I mean that's correct right
I agree yeah if you have a father who
says I want the baby to live and a woman
who says don't know don't care the state
lets me do it you've got a very serious
moral Christ on your hands that's not
going to be solved by a a court order
that's correct every law can be passed
every judge can bang their gavel and the
father might still say you will not kill
my son yes and there will be a multitude
of these issues that are going to come
to the front and the question will be is
the Constitution still the law of the
Lend and it's crumbling in front of our
eyes
the Constitution is the greatest
political document ever written and we
are in a post-constitutional moment it's
brilliant founding fathers man yeah this
is this is because they built it on
Eternal wisdom and they knew central
banks were so dangerous yes they did
well even the National Bank was not
technically a central bank so you're
correct even Hamilton's idea of a
central bank would be different than
what our idea of a central bank where
like they run it out of Switzerland some
foreign
to the bank for international
settlements in Switzerland Hamilton's
idea of a national bank would have had
actual checks and balances by congress
not a separately chartered Federal
Reserve that is basically public private
but you're right even even Hamilton
would have found this current banking
system objectionable I understand that
there is a value of cohesion and having
a unified currency as a country it gives
us national identity we can all identify
with the dollar but we're in a we're in
a society where you can create your own
currency very easily with crypto so
maybe we just need to the whole Congress
handles money obviously they don't the
banking scandals offshore svb welcome to
bitcoin Sam bankman free yeah laundering
money through allegedly through his
company and now like so maybe we should
be able to all create our own currencies
I know it creates disillusion in some
way nationally you know cohesive sorry
Bitcoin is the decentralized store of
value that people are already using look
at us out of them but there's thousands
and you can create them on the fly right
it's going to be messy for a while the
the dollar is necessary though right now
you think we're divided now wait until
we have our everyone has their own
currency yeah no no wait until declining
Brazil and China have already cut a deal
Saudi Arabia and Iran are cutting a deal
China's brokering deals to end the Petro
dollar Americans are in for a very very
rude awakening it would impoverish this
country yeah empowers an understatement
I don't know yeah I don't know how you
would yeah concerned about decimate
apocalypse how about that yep economic
although apocalypse isn't necessarily
bad it just means like the Great
Awakening the great uh uncovering well
it means starvation
they take a negative connotation maybe
because it's near the end of the story
in the Bible is that why probably but in
reality now we're just it's becoming
disclosed we the curtain has been lifted
we see the chaos we know what the
Federal Reserve is now that they've
formed it behind the scenes in 1913 not
everyone knows but you do it's being
revealed daily to new people Trump was
part of that Steve bannon's greatest
talking about but yeah in like loose
change lucrutkowski these people have
been talking about it for 20 years so it
is a form of Apocalypse not necessarily
A Bad Thing what do we do with
disclosure don't let your mind go crazy
don't don't go crazy it I understand why
you may want to because like people are
going to lose their jobs and they're not
going to have any food or a way to feed
their children and that's going to be a
problem as a result of what as a result
of the complete collapse of the Petro
dollar
so we don't make things we don't we have
excellent things we make we make some
things let me make the can I make the
counter argument to all the doomsday
IPOs that don't actually have any
products well that is true there's a lot
there's a lot of Truth there so China
only represents about five percent of
our Imports less than people not Imports
are not Imports that's not correct our
total economic output so we could
survive without China but thankfully the
only benefit of this stupid proxy war in
Ukraine is that we're actually on okay
terms of Germany even though Germany
hates us right now they're going to be
fine with us Germany is a very
productive country they make stuff
Germany makes stuff and Germany is
basically a proxy sister economy of
America right they use the dollars the
world Reserve currency the year is
backed by the dollar Japan they make
stuff Japan and America are inseparable
especially with their Chinese skepticism
South Korea they make stuff they're
Inseparable the open question is what is
India going to do
that should be the whole Focus quite
honestly of this current government is
to make sure India does not fall into
the good graces of Russia or China
they're natural adversaries of China
shouldn't be a hard problem they hate
the Chinese they've never liked each
other there's there's Natural Built and
tension there and there's a massive
developing Market in Southeast Asia that
hates China they hate the CCP they want
to use the dollar Indonesia is a
fast-growing country the Philippines you
have Vietnam you have Cambodia of Laos
these are fast developing countries very
industrious people with ever increasing
property private property rights which
is a prerequisite to wealth creation and
be careful what you ask for the want is
manipulated China's economy is largely
built on a potemkin village you're right
we don't make stuff but this idea that
China has this Beast way to go
economically their house of cards too
and but it's not just about China it's
about the fact that we have been giving
away our manufacturing for a long time
in Mexico I totally agree with that but
I think we can onshore that a lot
quicker because we have the natural
production meaning we have the natural
production capability we have natural
resources right so so let's just say
China Cuts us off okay let's say they
say no more vitamin C okay we could ramp
up vitamin C production in this country
in 10 months if we wanted to we could do
it well Trump had that idea of starting
to bring a lot of penicillin should not
be made in all that stuff right you can
get ideas for like Kodak factories
upstairs that's right you take Vitamin C
out of black mold of all things right
yeah I mean the good stuff is yeah
unless it says naturally derived in the
ingredients from what I'm told it comes
from black mold that's creepy asparagus
negro is what it's called that's
interesting yeah I prefer for my oranges
yeah there's no reason why we have to
get that from China but the the I think
that this this Rush away from the dollar
is going to Flat Line we need regime
change in America Biden's got to go
Trump could fix this in a second he
would fix this agreed but there is a
there is a backstop here that I think
Brazil's a broken country the the Bulls
on Brazil have been wrong for years if
you go look up Brazil's GDP it's got
It's spiked and it's been going down
with the new Lula regime well scenario
just went home yeah and that's gonna be
open
India is the key all right everybody if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends and become a member at
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only uncensored show on the front page
of timcast.com live at about 10 10 p.m
are we gonna talk about this show sure
we'll talk about religion we've got some
other stories too that I think will lead
us right to the topic and we'll get into
all that and we will be taking callers
from our Discord server so become a
member at the 25 tier today and you'll
instantly join the VIP chat or sign up
at 10 bucks a month and in six months
you will instantly be upgraded the gate
is there simply to prevent it's a
screening process we're trying to do
what we can to keep out people who are
just trying you know screw with us try
this band or something like that all
right we have Vision 667 who says open
carry still illegal in Florida unless
you are carrying a fishing pole you can
open carry on your way to and or from a
fishing Expedition oh well that's
strange but they they just signed
concealed care I thought that they did
that yeah concealed carrying I don't
know conceals different than open so
permit lists uh concealed carry is that
it is yeah that was Florida yeah that's
amazing they pass is it now I think the
Santa's just uh yeah they signed it yeah
yeah let me uh I think constitutional
carry should be the law that land in all
50 states what I completely agree yep
because like I'm I was thinking actually
when we did uh am fest I've sealed carry
without a permit wow I think at am
Fester was security or it might have
even been due to the city you couldn't
have guns in there and I said on stage
with all of us there I would rather
everyone in that audience be armed
because it's my choice to be here to
speak in front of people and they I
shouldn't be allowed to disarm hundreds
of people now granted a a private
establishment I think has the rights to
say we don't want guns in our premises
my point is ideologically and personally
I would never tell a crowd of people you
can't defend yourselves because I'm
scared of maybe one of you nah I just
won't go on stage if I'm ever scared but
you know what hey someone might do
something crazy Welcome to the Real
World it sucks I don't like it but I'm
not gonna infringe upon someone else's
rights because a Criminal Mind exist
it's just crazy to me you know and we
must be very clear about what is the
purpose of the Second Amendment the
Second Amendment is there for individual
people to prevent them to protect
themselves against tyranny against a
usurptation government there is a price
to All Things the cost of having a
second amendment Is tragically you're
gonna have some numb skulls misuse that
therefore The Prudent thing to do is to
protect what you care about with armed
guards schools every school should have
an armed guard and people say oh Charlie
does that mean you want the
militarization of our country our
airports are militarized our banks are
militarized our sporting events are
militarized it should be able to protect
our kids yes I mean our kids can have an
armed guard outside there I don't think
that's going to phase anybody in any
sort of damaging way I think that's a
silly argument so Tim I already
mentioned we should get ex-military to
like totally one soldier because they
need jobs yep the red says I remember
the media making fun of trump for having
two scoops of ice cream at a state
dinner since Biden took office there
have been Zero Ice Cream related facts
checks I don't know if I believe that
there's that Biden's always getting ice
cream yeah it's a lot of ice cream a lot
of ice cream sugar man you do know that
ice cream helps people with dementia not
a joke
it releases dopamine and ice cream
serotonin it's fantastic it is wonderful
relaxes I think the prefrontal cortex
and makes people with dementia more
present I'm not kidding you fact check
it type in ice cream dementia
all right Joe spinella says the judge in
The Rittenhouse case is a Democrat and
democrat-appointed judge
but was it the jury wasn't it the jury
that returned yes but remember how fair
that judge was to Kyle Tim
uh-huh so it just kind of validates my
my point you think the judge was fair to
Kyle Rittenhouse yeah of course remember
how that judge scoring the prosecution
and said you don't put this garbage in
our courtroom and this is Nazi almost
threw the entire trial out because the
prosecution was basically angling for a
mistrial all right remember how that guy
ended up getting called lunchbox yep I
mean my concern is that there was very
obvious manipulated evidence there was
direct evidence of evidence tampering
and the the video footage from the Drone
was clearly AI generated and they
allowed all of that and that was
shocking to me I think that's a fair
Counterpoint if I remember correctly I'm
drawing from memory the judge also
challenged a fair amount remember the
prosecutorial questioning where they
were leading the questioner and the
judge says you know better than that and
you don't do that that was a harsh and
that was public that was publicly
televised that was a condemnation there
there was a video of what was it um
there was it was editing software that's
correct on his desktop
and it's like you know handbrake I think
it was called yeah something like that I
can't remember the exact details so that
just proves my point Tim the prosecution
and con in that particular case crumbled
when people like Tim cast and passobic
and Drew Hernandez started to do what
you guys do and to post millennial human
events as soon as all these different
angles started to be examined it went
viral and the local prosecution crumbled
I think there's an element of that these
guys are not ready for prime time at the
local DA's office in New York they're
not they're they're going to be sloppy
in how they write indictments they're
going to be sloppy how they cover
evidence and we're going to see
everything we're going to expose it and
they're going to be uncomfortable
because the national media is going to
be covering every turn is that going to
be enough to keep Trump out of jail
Maybe
all right Cody Griffin says Tim we must
stop with this Trump versus DeSantis
fake Feud it is designed to divide us
because we fully recognize the common
enemy if Trump Des Anderson Lake teamed
up they would be unstoppable I agree
yeah I agree
um I I don't think there's a reason to
look I I think Trump and DeSantis going
head-to-head could be the most
beneficial thing for the Republicans
going forward in that they both will
make each other stronger competition
will will breed that growth in my
opinion there's no reason to make it
dark though you know what I mean it
should be above board on the level
DeSantis can be like here's why here's
where I disagree with Trump trump can
say here's the issue with the sentence
and if Trump doesn't tactful
Independence does as well then both
candidates become substantially more
more powerful
cleaner better more appealing Etc
all right
what do we got here the jaded kriegsman
says Republicans need to realize
sometimes to fight your opponent you
have to go down in the gutter with them
we need to do to them what they do to us
I think that's what you were saying was
with the indictments correct criminally
charge them yes and there's plenty of
crimes to go around
plenty start with BLM
all right feral 81 says or Pharrell
anyone question for Charlie what's the
current progress on organizing legal
ballot harvesting the GOP won't win in
2024 if it doesn't happen doesn't matter
the candidates or the issues ballot
harvesting needs to be the only goal
yes so ballot harvesting is not legal in
the three states we need to win but
ballot chasing is it's a technical
definition so you can't touch a ballot
now the Democrats do it all the time in
Arizona Georgia Wisconsin so turning
point action we are building the most
robust sophisticated and aggressive
early vote operation I have a complete
philosophical change on this I used to
think everyone show up on election day
it's going to be great we've done a 180
we did in an introspection I'm not going
to lose we're playing to win so what is
ballot chasing ballot chasing is
politely reminding and persuading people
to go vote early and you have a person
with a thousand names and you're going
to chase those ballots till they're
submitted and you have 100 people doing
that or 250 people doing that the
Democrats have perfected this they are
banking votes while we are hoping votes
will happen while doing it as securely
as possible for low propensity
Republican voters and
when with mail-in voting which will
still be in effect to a certain degree
because once people sign up in many
states they just keep getting there's no
reversing it's like a welfare check all
you do is knock on the door and say hey
is that a you should fill that out
that's right and you encourage them you
can't touch the ballot but here's what
you can do you can say Hey you know
Sally Sue Marie I know you're a
registered Republican oh I hate buy it
and all that and they'll say something
like this what's the point in voting the
system's so broke that's gonna be the
number one piece of persuasion and so if
you can convince them that it's still a
moral duty to vote and be like hey I can
walk you to the mailbox or I can drive
you to the voting processing center all
of a sudden now you're actively involved
in the process of banking votes I'll
give you a simple one I call it we'll
call it Trump's wager
you you knock on a door and there's uh
middle-aged dude and you can see he's
got a stack of mail hey look at that a
universal mail-in vote was at his house
and he says look I hate Biden but what's
the point it's not going to matter
anyway then I say this
if you don't vote and it doesn't matter
then you're fine
if you don't vote but it does matter
then you're helping Joe Biden that's the
best way I heard it if you do vote and
it doesn't matter
then nothing happens right if you do
vote and it does matter you are stopping
Joe Biden So based on that wager that
grid the only action that makes sense is
to vote
your worst case scenario is you lose 30
seconds filling out that mail-in ballot
questions about just voting vote chasing
um you can't touch the ballot yeah not
those three states I imagine you can't
put gloves on and pick up about can you
can you pick up the person if the ballot
is in their hand that's a good question
I don't think so can you talk to Arizona
and Wisconsin yeah can you push a
wheelchair uh yeah so you can assist
somebody in the transportation of going
to a voting Center yeah so you can have
somebody with their ballot get in your
car and drive them there to a secure
place to submit the ballot what about
the thing on the ballot where it says
did someone help you fill this out and
have them write on it so that that's a
sep yeah that's an interesting question
I don't know the answer to that
um and so we're I'll have to find out
okay I don't know the answer to that
so
all right let's see what do we have here
let me grab a Super Chat ma says the
left FBI will pretend to be Trump
supporters tomorrow and start riots
there will be many fake actors ready to
put blame on Maga I wouldn't be
surprised I mean we know for a fact they
were cops yelling at people to go go go
keep going on the ground that's
definitively reported we know that there
were informants that's not definitively
reported then the New York Times
reported there was an unusual number of
informants involved in the proud boys
that's right and then you have the
questions of what why Ray Epps is what
was it someone tweeted I think was
Marjorie Taylor Greener or somebody that
the FBI sells a picture of him as wanted
right they've totally like now took it
off the website didn't they I don't know
something like that
so whatever I guess yeah I mean look the
the amount of federal involvement on
January 6 remains a mystery
do you like it do you think it will
always remain a mystery do you think I
think that look when something corrupt
happens there's openings and attack
vectors
and there's a very easy attack vector
and I mean that in the most moral way
meaning trying to expose the lies that
no one is properly exploited the pipe
bombs
yeah this says uh you've mentioned this
Tim like the pipe bombs are the
low-hanging fruit who planted those
bombs both at the RNC and the DNC was
obviously a federal agent the bombs
never went off they haven't arrested
anybody they don't have a suspect of
Interest they used geolocation cell
phone ping technology to find gram
grannies that took selfies in the
capital yet we don't have a suspect of
interest for someone that could have
created a smaller version of the
Oklahoma City bombing at the RNC that's
highly suspicious and so I I've always
said the pipe bombs are the key to the
whole thing you uncover who planted the
pipe bombs you're going to find a whole
Treasure Trove of answers they use the
pipe bombs to like escalate charges
no one's been arrested so remember the
RNC and DNC are about three blocks from
Capitol Hill and as The Story Goes
apparently the night you could fact
check me but the night before the
morning of a suspicious character at
both the RNC and the DNC drops off some
bags on the outside of it
that were pipe bombs and they never went
off they never detonated but remember
the sequence of events that happened
that day because it was all such a blur
but as the quote-unquote capital was
being breached almost simultaneously
after Trump was that we all got push
notifications that pipe bombs were
discovered at both the RNC and the DNC
and that became a very de-emphasized
part of the story right which by the way
if those bombs would have went off would
have been the most Criminal Intent that
happened that entire day that's
legitimate political terrorism yeah like
actual political terrorism not someone
that gets heated and gets in a shoving
match outside of the capital rotunda
right not someone that gets put into a
mob frenzy someone that goes through the
intent of trying to create a pipe bomb
and putting outside of both the RNC and
the DNC who does that
and not one person's been arrested we
have no suspects of Interest we have we
haven't used the cell phone ping
technology that we use to go find the
grannies in the capital towards that you
want the answers on January 6 and the
fed's involvement look into the
pipelines you asked who does that I was
thinking well Foreigner that's first
time I've really thought that there
would be foreign involvement with
January 6th but it doesn't surprise I
wouldn't surprise if that's the case I
mean maybe that's a foreign intelligence
agency maybe it's a foreign actor I have
no idea the fact the bombs didn't go off
and the how did they find them too and
why did they find them almost the exact
same time at the RNC and the DNC they
found them like oh wow just uh we were
gardening here and there's a bum and
what it did was it created a a diversion
a pretext for the evacuation of Congress
that's Congressional buildings an hour
to cause Panic amongst Congress no to
evacuate them one hour before the
capitol was actually breached to
minimize actual harm to members of
Congress
so AOC told her famous story about
they're here or whatever it was just
very top but her story took place an
hour before the breach happened so how
would she have known anyone could get to
her but she just made that she made up a
lot of the details either AOC had
foreknowledge of what was going to
happen to the capitol or she fabricated
the story I've never well I mean AOC
making up a story sounds more plausible
no of course but but I don't think they
would treat her I don't think they would
trust her with deep state Secretary
that when the pounding came at her door
she thought that they got to her her
office and found her and that she was
hiding in the back that's a really
interesting point I've never heard
anyone make that point well I've been I
was I don't watch it every night Tim I'm
sorry every night when this all went
down the Republicans all said AOC wasn't
even in the Capitol building the media
responded Yes but they're all connected
by tunnels and then I responded except
her story took place one hour before the
capital was a breach so she would not
have known the capital was breached she
lied and made the story up she's a nasty
person she could be a Fed I think she's
just evil I I think she just decided to
make up a fake story for social media
points did you see her uh allegedly
burner account on Twitter yeah I don't
know if I believe that either smoker it
would be real and I could make an
account and then respond to someone
tweeting at you Libby saying the exact
same thing then delete it and everyone
will be like oh look Libby's account
it's not proof of anything peer delecto
wasn't that the name of yeah Romney's
yeah but that was confirmed wasn't it
yeah I'm saying it wouldn't be the first
time a lawmaker had a burner account
right right
yeah it's funny when you know people
claim that I'm running burners or
whatever like everyone's got one but I
don't even check my mentions on Twitter
like these people just think that
everyone cares so much about you that's
why I'm like I don't believe that AOC is
doing this honestly Tim you got me
convinced she's a total fed and like
that explains her whole rise I think
you're you're on to something here you
think ASC is a fed I'm not I'm half
joking half joking which means I could
be right right oh see I'm sorry we're
gonna have to see your credentials here
are you a Fed are you a creation of the
deep State security project what explain
why she votes for Aid to Ukraine even
though she pretends she's anti-war right
that's true all right mind Fury 1980
says Ian watch the Orville majority rule
as to why a democratic technocracy is a
terrifying idea Orville majority rule
yeah Orville's a good show I mean it got
kind of weird lately but you know I
agree that a democratic technocracy
would be horrific but so that's why I
want like a technocratic republic I you
know I don't want the mob in control of
anything right now
all right villainous black dragon
entertainment says Tim and Kirk do you
think Trump is playing 5D chess by using
the left's tactic and play victim
I wouldn't call it five D chess I would
call it checkers
like the Democrats were trying not to
indict Trump and then this low-level
dude does and Trump goes oh no better
raise five million dollars overnight and
then go and get a Reign that's you know
his polls are skyrocketing his revenue
is skyrocketing they're helping him and
it's funny because they're trying now
politicize that article let's don't
overthink it an indictment would be bad
for Trump he won't gain a single new
voter and I'm like well you just did
yeah the polls are showing he's got a
whole bunch of new donors first-time
donors
sorry do I think he's playing Five D
chess no I think it's actually suit I
think I agree with you it's more like
tic-tac-toe it's not even checkers
yes it's like one move two move three in
a row I mean this is not that hard right
you're going to turn me into a victim
I'll happily play the role after I've
been
you know the villain he went from
villain to Victor overnight it was such
a bad move by the uh by the brag what
were they if they really want to beat
him in an election why would you Pariah
the guys the question I mean there is
there is a belief out there I find it to
be unsubstantiated that they want Trump
to be the nominee and therefore they're
doing this I find that to be silly Kyle
Bigelow says billions printed for covid
Ukraine and Banks now arresting a man
who 75 million voted for 12 days before
productivity
self-incrimination day just saying
you know what that means tax days in 12
days I see productivity
self-incrimination
pay your taxes everybody that's right
damn I gotta do that yeah I'm actually
excited I think I'm gonna get a refund
you know because I I agree I gave the
government too much money good for you
yeah yeah they should be very happy
about that my accountant were tired oh
oh well all right Admar says what does
the 17th Amendment mean to me Amy
Klobuchar and Tina Smith giving a
generic auto reply email and I'm
probably put on a list to be audited we
should repeal the 17th Senators should
be appointed by the states that's what
this the Senators are supposed to
represent the state's interests well and
Minnesota had a red legislature up until
recently so what it mean for you it
means that you would have a Republican
senator to Minnesota that hasn't
happened I think I don't think
Republicans have had a senator you could
track check me in Minnesota since like
1952. would it be the kind of thing
where if a new state senator comes in
that they would just recall the federal
essentially yeah they would be they
would be serving at the will of the
state legislative body
that's nice too because it makes
Senators more accountable to their
actual States and constitutions they
came in for hearings Senators used to
come into for hearings
so for example you'd have South Carolina
say hey what are you doing are you
fighting for our values you know let's
have a hearing here yeah meetings
Senators should be accountable to their
state definitely that's good that's the
foundation to each individual so we got
rid of that with the 17th Amendment
which was supposed to be progress when
it was really I think regression yeah my
nipple says can Libby write a zeppelin
story to use as a source
write a zeppelin story well the issue is
we have the video of of us building the
Zeppelin and it's got it's got um you
know uh let's go Brandon on the side of
it that was Luke's flag and we're flying
it around and streaming from it so that
YouTube video is good enough anyone
could just put that on Wikipedia that
Tim Poole invented a zeppelin the issue
is
there was an old story claiming it was
true and then after like seven years
they removed it and then I demanded they
restore it now that I did in fact build
a zeppelin retroactively making the
article true but they remove it because
it's the reason I did it was it's an
interesting question about the article
said I invented a zeppelin at the time I
didn't but now I did as a live streaming
Zeppelin modification
if the article is now factually true why
would they not allow the article to be
honest you're not a primary source no no
it's not for me it's from like it was
from like uh Forbes or something
so the question is
if the article is true now it wasn't a
time is it a legitimate source
right is Forbes a legitimate Source
if it wasn't my point is if a news
article says Charlie Kirk does backflip
he never did and then five years later
he does do a backflip the fact that it
says Charlie Kirk has done a backflip is
now true and correct despite it it's
actually still incorrect because the
date on the article uh is not actually
reflective of when the thing happened
but the date is still fake but I don't
think the date reflects the statement
made the date reflects the time the
statement was made but the statement is
now true the statement is now at the
time so I guess that's the issue that
I'm testing that was the intent
how how can if there is a historical
article reference saying Donald Trump
never did thing and then he later goes
and does it that reference is or I'm
sorry if it says Donald Trump did a
thing he didn't do and then he does do
it it's now an it's now accurate the
fake news becomes accurate you know what
I mean I I think it wouldn't be accurate
so what do they do they rewrite the
story and say update the exact same
terminology so and what they would do is
right it's like saying that Donald Trump
is dead he's not but eventually he will
be and so he has died but it would say
update at the time of this article it
was not true but at the time of writing
it now is when you publish something
matters it's critical in journalism can
we get social media to clip the thing
where Charlie just said I was right also
I'm wondering about like you're
referencing an article like if it says
Tim pool Pet's dog and it shows a
picture of you petting a gray dog but
you're like I never did that and then 10
years later you pet a brown dog it
doesn't make the because the reference
of the word dog is a different dog it's
a different reference I think that's the
same word I just but but like that
you're talking about a common occurrence
of petting a dog and I think the issue
is inventing A zeppelin is a very very
very specific thing to do it's still
alive I get it fake news stories it's
just like a weird circumstance I suppose
all right let's see let's grab some more
what do we got here
otaku magnet says Federal politicians
believe they are serving their districts
this is a falsehood they serve all
Americans due to the positions they have
we need to return all power back to the
States and localities I agree
absolutely Gabriel Lopez says Ian anyone
can spin up a Wikipedia right now yet no
one does it because it would be useless
I'm a 20-year software engineer code
does not matter I rewrite stuff every
five years it's usually less than five
percent of the cost of building the
software business building a software
business uh people actually do spit up
their own Wikipedia's there's a bunch of
different versions of Wikipedia there's
like Wiki quote and then there's Wikia
forums where people will create
Wikipedia like encyclopedias for
everything yes Simpsons Wikia and you
know my hero Academia Wikia
Dragon Ball Z
and it's and the funny thing about it is
they always refer to fictional
characters in the past tense for some
reason which I don't get whatever
all right Leo Malto says congrats
Charlie just won the 2024 general
election how do you fix the
administrative State and handle these
corrupt DA's
uh you repeal you immediately enact I
think it's called title 50.
um or whatever it is that allows Donald
Trump to Fire Federal officials at will
schedule F schedule F yeah yeah you
immediately put it I
if you want I will vote for Trump
if he does one thing right now
if Donald Trump puts out a video where
he's wearing a hood like the emperor and
he goes execute schedule F and then it
plays the Star Wars song and then you
see a bunch of people 66 or whatever
it's called right and then it's a people
carrying boxes out of offices and it
plays a Star Wars theme and it's all
dramatic and then Trump goes I would be
like I am voting for him and nothing
will stop at this point he needs the
Santas could ride a pegasus into the
sunlight with a golden sword Trump did
the thing with the schedule F I just get
my vote schedule F immediately he needs
to decentralize Washington DC I probed
this during the first term and it was
met
um with total deaf ears so I hope in the
new Administration we could do this you
need to pick you need to look at the
cabinet you need to say okay Veterans
Affairs is going to Florida Department
of the Interior is going to Colorado you
know you go through one by one right
Health and Human Services you have to
break up the centrality of Washington DC
you have to put the agencies actually
into the country that they serve this
would make it harder for lobbyists to
navigate you'd get a better pool of
employees you would actually create
wealth more in these states and it would
create a cool idea oh yeah it's it's
where should Biden's massive medical
industrial complex expansion go New
Jersey that's fair and then if the power
goes out they go back to the capital
what do you mean like because that it
works decentralizing until the phone
lines get shut down and then but if
they're operating
necessarily need to but but they would
be all over the country right so the
vision would be you would pick you'd
pick states that actually make sense to
the constituents they're serving so the
department of the Interior should be
where there's the most federal lands
Nevada Colorado Utah Montana Idaho
Wyoming right you you look at you know
another another agency Department of
Education right
um I think you should send that to a red
state so a red State that's doing things
great Arizona Arizona has the best
school choice the point is that you
reallocate these Federal departments out
of the kingdom of Washington DC and then
you actually change the personnel and
that's one of the ways that you actually
change the administrative State and the
third thing is that Personnel is policy
and Trump needs to get 50 absolute Stone
Cold Killers around him if he wins
another term that are ready to go fire
people immediately Purge the bureaucracy
of these double-minded people and just
issue pink slip after pink slip after
pink slip so the the they say some say
he never drained the swamp others say he
did drain the swamp and it exposed the
swamp monsters under the water and if
that's the case now he needs to come
down and gently guide these folks into a
a nice bus where they can be driven off
to comfortably retire and send little
chairs in sun rooms and then I wish them
nothing but happiness but away from the
seats of government yes and so Trump
term two he needs to govern with urgency
and a Vengeance against these very
people that tried to impeach him twice
people that have destroyed this Con that
have tried to destroy this country and
the administrative State needs to be the
primary focus of trump term two it is is
out of control it's unchecked these are
people are unelected they have unknown
amounts of power you don't even know the
face to them and I mean just the CDC
alone is worthy of just a massive Purge
let alone the FBI the Vengeance thing
makes me nervous because I was watching
Hitler's speeches last night and when
you hear when you have an enemy and
you're campaigning and you're like that
the bad guy the bad guy your people in
the crowd screaming stuff like get him
and you're like no no we're not doing
that to this world I I we it is a
problem the Deep state is a big problem
that they don't have term limits but I
think we could create something that
helps everybody and also evolve the
system so that there's less of a bloat
Let's uh let's read one more here we got
Nibiru says the permit list carry in
Florida takes effect July 1st they
finally put aged by Firearms back to 18.
got to take the win DeSantis for
president won't happen also Matt gates
for Florida Governor 2027 and bocus
espresso blend for the win ah Perhaps
Perhaps uh yeah bogus espresso might be
good all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends if you really
do like it because word of mouth is the
most impo most powerful way that
podcasts actually succeed and become a
member at timcast.com head over to
timcast.com click join us sign up for
the Discord server because in our
members only uncensored show going live
in about 10 minutes on the front page of
timcast.com we will be taking your calls
and you can ask all of us questions and
it's uh it's good fun it's my favorite
part of the day to be completely honest
I love getting to answer questions from
the community and that's another thing
we're doing we're going to be launching
this thing where our Friday sponsor spot
instead of doing some company will just
be one of our members so if one of our
members has a company we will figure out
how to do the proper decision making but
we'll just be like today's episode is
brought to you by our members today's
member is you know so and so who runs a
company building Widgets or whatever and
we're really excited for this it was
actually the community that came up with
the idea and it was brilliant so I
really do appreciate the support so
smash that like button subscribe to this
Channel and and again become a member at
timcast.com you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast everywhere Charlie do you
want to shout anything out I do uh
everybody if you would be as kind it's
free of charge subscribe to our podcast
the Charlie Kirk Show podcast we do
three podcasts a day we're live on 140
radio stations every day uh 12 to 3.
we're also live on real America's voice
Rumble and YouTube but the best way to
support us is you take out the phone and
you open up the podcast app of your
choice apple or Spotify are the two big
ones type in Charlie Kirk show and hit
that subscribe button it blesses us
significantly always interesting guests
Libby's on frequently Tim we had you on
for long form it was fabulous
um and so if you guys would be so kind
of subscribe it really helps us out
right on so I also would like to pump
memberships we took a cue from utim
actually and we have memberships now at
the post-millennial and human events and
for five dollars a month you can go ad
free uh the ads are the things that
everybody hates about the post
millennial everyone loves our work we
have great contributors um we have Jack
besobic who's a senior editor at human
events Andy no is also a senior editor
we have Savannah Hernandez Charlie of
course is a contributor to human events
as well yeah and so we have a lot of
great work we have a lot of great talent
and we hope that you sign up for that at
thepostmillennial.com
subscribe so I hope that you do that and
also I'm going to be coming up at the
mines Fest in Austin I think you guys
are all going to be there on April 15th
at the Vulcan theater in Austin so um
you know I'm a late addition to the
lineup but I'm glad to be there and
tickets are available tickets Dot
vulcanpresents.com
and I hope to see everyone out there
I'll also be there uh always a pleasure
my man we should do a show and talk
about God I think we're doing that we're
next on the members on Charlie Kirk show
someday because I welcome you for an
hour okay we're going to do a short
version here much love Charlie thanks so
thanks for coming out I'm a big Ian fan
pleasure thanks for the data dog all
right guys love you take care of
yourself
hey uh good to see you Charlie as always
thank you um yeah good show uh please
call in guys you should become a member
it's actually really fun to do
um yeah let's go we'll see you all uh go
to timcast.com right on the front page
in about 10 minutes you will see the
uncensored show you click on it boom
you're there and we'll see y'all there
thanks for hanging out